my friends
the left many of these critical race
theorists type people they don't like me
so they have to claim that what i do is
not journalism but it's wrong
while i'll be the first to admit most of
what i do is political commentary
cultural commentary and news commentary
etc
no i actually do the digging and this
morning when i wake up
i go and i look at all of these
different news stories claiming
that reddit is pumping silver that
they've decided gamestop
gamestop is is out no one cares anymore
and everybody should go by
silver and i thought that sounds weird
that doesn't sound like reddit
they wouldn't just stop they've been
saying diamond hands you know hold the
stock don't sell
so i go to reddit what do i see the
number one post on the entire website
not just wall street bets is
don't buy silver bloomberg ran a segment
titled redditors lose interest in
gamestop
and it has never been more brazen
the desperation from the machine over
what reddit has done
is it's it's they are so desperate in
fact
they're completely exposing themselves
and this has been a trend over the past
several months
you can now go to reddit show your
friends and family hey looks the other
saying don't buy silver it's a scam and
fake news
here's every mainstream outlet you know
and trust lying to your face
it's crazy but we've got some big news
too
you see the game is rigged my friends
it's not just it's just it's not just
the media but apparently the nscc which
is the the principal clearing house for
stocks
told robin hood the trading app that
they had
to deposit three billion dollars secured
deposit
and when they eventually negotiated down
saying we can't do that they said 700
million i believe it was 700 maybe
actually be yeah i believe it was 700
million
but you also have to freeze these stocks
when you finally find a way to win they
shut you down
now initially i titled this podcast it
was the feds why
because the initial story that i had
said federer federal regulator
intervenes
and turns out nscc is actually a private
entity a subsidiary of the dtcc
and as ian put it we were discussing
this like trying to figure out
what the right title would be said it's
convoluted on purpose so we've got a
bunch of crazy news today it's not just
about what's going on with the gamestop
rebellion
because i do think that's important but
we also have you know unrest in
rochester after cops
pepper sprayed a nine year old girl
we've got the swat
team raiding the red lion hotel because
left-wing activists
occupied it we've got china threatening
war
over taiwanese independence has a lot to
go through joining us today of course i
mentioned ian he's chilling well hello
everyone
thanks for coming and thanks for having
me tim you were mentioning that it was
convoluted on purpose it's insane dude
it's like the federal
federal express which i don't know if
they really wanted you to think it was
actually a federal company but the
of course the federal reserve also not a
federal company an arm of the bank of
international settlements a swiss bank
one of many uh central banks throughout
the world like the bank of england and
the bank of australia
that are not uh governed by their
government this is ian's time to shine
hello the federal reserve all this stuff
that's what i was thinking when i looked
at nscc i was like wait is this not
uh what is this entity it's not
regulated it's not part of the
government it's a private entity
what is this because i was reading an
old article talking about how it was
effectively supposed to be
handling like some kind of regulatory
body like work it's not it's a private
event no and i think at some point it
would be fair to make it illegal to call
your company federal
anything that's like i would like i mean
federal express is legit just a private
company i know
but yeah it's just federal express just
a name it's a brand
just a name well we're getting all that
we got we got lucas hey hey if you could
if you can make yourself
sound official you are official that's
the rules by the internet
i mean right am i wrong yeah also when
you look at silver and when you type it
into google the first articles that come
up first google puts up a big memo it
says silver prices surge to eight year
high but the first article
is by the wall street journal that says
silver prices jump
in game stop like frenzy then it's the
new york times
silver rises with hype it's the next
game stop and again
just absolute propaganda disinformation
which of course we're going to be
countering here welcome back beautiful
and amazing human beings this is
lucadowski of we are change.org
you want to get involved with what i'm
doing i have many different ways you can
on we are change.org forward slash
donate because you do i'm here thank you
ladies and gentlemen we got an awesome
sponsor today oh yeah uh a big shout out
to safeanreadymeals.com this
is emergency food supplies you can go to
safeandreadymeals.com we've got
a two-week food supply there's a
four-week food supply and uh you get a
fairly a decent around 20
or so discount when you go and pick up
this uh this food it lasts about 25
years if stored properly
and uh it's really that simple it's this
big bucket you get you peel it open you
got a bunch of different bags of stuff
inside
it's it's really easy to do you open a
bag you put in a pot you mix it with
some water it's fantastic
and one of the reasons we're doing a
shout out for safeandreadymeals.com is
because
uh for those of you that don't live on
the east coast we're currently being
slammed by a blizzard
and we i went out because i wanted to i
had to go run some errands
everything is shut down i live in the
middle of nowhere so we don't have a lot
of good road service or anything like
that
everything's closed kfc was closed the
restaurants were all closed
it was it was uh particularly difficult
so you know we did
we came back and we actually had one of
these we cracked open and we used
pancake mix as a deep-frying batter it
was fantastic
so i'm not saying you need an emergency
food supply
but i am saying this sometimes like
actually let me
phrase it this way a lot of people think
this stuff is all about the apocalypse
buy this stuff because you think the
world is ending that's not the case
we have some because sometimes it snows
so bad
that it's hard to get to the store and
we're like well let's see we got in the
pantry
turns out we ran out of bacon and other
food and we were gonna go to the store
and then we didn't and then we should
have
i don't know if you guys have ever seen
that that viral video where the guy
screaming
you got to get the milk bread and eggs
and he's running to his car because they
said snow
listen sometimes it snows sometimes it
rains and it makes it hard to go out and
buy stuff so
safeandreadymeals.com special thanks you
can pick up
your emergency food supply it's 25 20 or
so percent off when you go check it out
they're they're trying to say something
yeah there was no eggs at the
supermarket i just came from there i
barely made it
but i also barely made it here and i
live in the parking lot that's how bad
it
to the store and then you were trying to
make it back and you were having trouble
yeah yeah yeah but you know like
i did and uh everyone's going 20 miles
an hour and i still have to shovel the
snow off of my rv which i'm not
oh we got to get another video it was it
was we went to a mexican restaurant it
was closed and there was no signs or
anything and we were confused
and then i was like i don't understand
what's happening and so like we drove
around and everything was empty
with no notifications and then i was
like did we
did they get raptured or something like
they're just gone because of kova
they're looking for an excuse
they're slow anyway and so no it's a
blizzard bro no it's a place
it might be a combination we went to one
restaurant conspiracy
we went to one restaurant and finally
this thing on the door saying due to
inclement weather we will we will be
shutting down
and i'm like dude we went we went to one
place it's like an adventure center with
a with a with food
and it's like supposed to be for like
hiking even they were closed
so i was like we went back we cracked up
one of these boxes and we used the
the instant pancake mix as deep frying
better i just want to add great
about safe and ready meals one once you
crack it open you can use the bucket as
a trash can that's really cool
yeah correct those those are really good
pancake
batter dips we made deep fried we bacon
we had to find bacon we found bacon at
the gas station and uh deep fried
mozzarella which is not
that was awesome dude it worked out so
well delicious
yeah so we had a guest here and he was
like
hey can i have one of those safe and
ready things and i was like what are you
are you crazy he's like yeah ever since
i was here last time and you gave it to
me i really want another one
so i mixed him up one of those while he
was here and i was like that's really
weird but i'm really glad you enjoy it
doesn't look like they're mac and cheese
yeah it's like it's like you get a
packet you put in a bucket that was a
really long promo yeah i thought
i thought it was a funny story like
that's why we were shouting them out
because i'm like
you know we're in this blizzard right
now and i'm like this is it
the people want to embarrass you and
they want to talk they want to smack
talk me saying oh
you souls food buckets i'm like yes and
now sometimes there's a blizzard it
shuts the roads down you can't go to the
store
you can just crack one of these things
open worst case scenarios you eat food
we deep fried it in peanut oil by the
way
yeah we did bacon wrapped chicken and
then breaded and deep fried which was
it was probably not the healthiest thing
in the world okay anyway go to
teamcast.com become a member
and check out we actually have a bonus
episode we deal with elizabeth talking
about
a bunch of things youtube will ban us
for talking about and it was a pretty
serious conversation
um so again tbs.com you can become a
member 10 bucks a month and you get
access to all this
special bonus content and we'll be
producing more as things ramp up my
friends
seriously we have been working like way
over time we're bringing in more people
to help because
um too many members it's the website is
doing too
too good too good you guys are awesome i
love you all so much
uh seriously we got such a massive
influx of members it overloaded the
system we're
we're trying to get member support to
help everybody's having problems and
we're getting there but if you want to
make sure that uh when we do get banned
we'll still exist in some form you can
go to timcast.com sign up
now that was probably the longest
opening segment we've ever done
but look i gotta be honest i really
wanted to talk about the blizzard
because
i still want to talk about deep frying
food yes that's my wheelhouse
this is blizzard it's like news and it's
fun because there's snow everywhere
i mean i got i got a big truck with some
cajones on it and that thing was moving
around not too good out there yeah you
got four by four yeah yeah and that was
even a little sketchy out there but
my my dog really loves the snow so he's
going crazy video of her yeah she's
going absolutely
i'm exploiting it to the fullest extent
by the way on my instagram luke we are
changing just
you know just as a couch oh she loves us
this has been
your weather report hey guess i already
by the way
news i looked up a utah's government
website explained that we really are
still in an ice age so that last 12
800 years ago we were peppered by comets
and the glaciers melted but we're still
in like the interglacial part of the ice
age where it's receding so this warming
is actually probably kind of normal and
we're just headed out
you saw climate change deny it yeah
check out ice age
utah and you'll you can read all about
it well we're not here to talk about the
weather anymore my friends i want to
show you
google take a look at this go to google
and type in silver and reddit and you
see all these top stories
silver is the new short squeeze target
for reddit traders
these market analysts blah blah blah
move over gamestop reddit traders are
targeting
silver now new york post reddit's epic
silver squeeze is only helping wall
street
this is the most brazen and insane
fake news i have ever seen i apologize
to those of you who have watched the
rest of my content
throughout the day because this is the
main thing i've been harping on in every
single video i don't really do that
sometimes i'll get you know
sometimes but this is the craziest thing
i've ever seen seriously
share this uh okay look let me let me
show you this post right here from wall
street bets
it is a bloom someone's watching
bloomberg and you can see it says this
woman emma chandra of bloomberg news
and then underneath retail traders lose
interest in gamestop
that is 100 fake news
the number one post right now on i
believe the number one post on wall
street bets
why you definitely should not under any
circumstances fall for the silver scams
you are being played by the most
powerful elite on the planet
think about what they say in that new
york post article reddit's epic silver
squeeze
is only helping wall street there is no
epic silver squeeze
it doesn't exist if silver is going up
and it did
earlier today it's because the media is
pumping it
now this is where things like the i'm
sorry man
the veil has been shattered we're seeing
two things right now
two things the first they don't like
that gamestop has
actually the the game stop retail
investors are actually
hurting the hedge funds melvin capital
down 53 they don't like it
so what we're seeing now is i believe
this is more likely to be some kind of
standalone complex where all these
people in media
have connections they get fake stories
seated and then
dumb journalists with malicious
journalists who are trying to make a
pretty penny
pump out this story to divert everyone's
attention away from
gamestop a lot of the people who are
investing are probably just someone who
saw the news
there's now eight million users on r
slash wall street bets eight million
a good portion of them probably just
tuned in as a get rich quick scheme
not all of them not most but just a lot
right i think what we're seeing is that
these
these special interests these elites are
trying to convince people
go buy dogecoin go buy go buy silver but
we're seeing something else
more nefarious than ever we are seeing
exactly why wall street bets is doing
what they're doing
we are seeing the crony machine in play
they are lying to you to get you to buy
silver
so they can pump the price of silver up
then all of their friends will
sell out when silver peaks leave you
holding an empty bag
they do it all the time and they're
doing it in our face right now
now it's not not just the new york post
there it's also cnbc that has this
headline
silver jumps eight percent touches eight
year high
as redditch traders try their squeeze
play
with the medal and when you look at the
media coverage it it definitely kind of
changed it was always sinister it was
always
extremely negative towards redditers
towards the plebes or peasants who are
actually gaining
some financial uh wisdom
and outsmarting the wall street guys it
was always negative towards them because
they're not part of the in club
they're not part of the establishment
but but we have to understand it's
always coming from the same kind of
point of view it's always coming from
the same kind of perspective
washington post wrote an opinion piece
about the hedge funds
being the good guys we have msnbc
literally
had an anchor on there talking about how
the redditch traders
are going to be self-harming themselves
like instagram women who are depressed
that they're going to start cutting
themselves because they're wasting their
time
i'm not kidding you it's absolutely
bonkers and absolutely
just insane the coverage we're seeing by
msnbc and then of course we also had
jimmy kimmel on oh yeah television
to the national public talking about
these amateur investors
who are maybe influenced by russia
literally yes russian developer russian
it was
that was exactly what he said but look
at the obfuscation look at the
manipulation look at the disinformation
propaganda campaign used against
individuals the plebes who are finally
playing in the stock market
by the rules of the hedge funds and the
hedge funds and establishment are saying
wait wait wait wait
we could only win this game not you when
they're playing by the rules fairly it's
absolutely
insane it's it's borderline criminal
there if we lived in a fair
system and there was justice in this
world there would be some serious
criminal charges but there's not
janet yellen i mean she's on the take
here obviously getting paid in my
opinion
in my opinion she's on the take but but
she's getting paid hundreds of thousands
of dollars from these companies
these companies have a revolving door
within the us federal reserve
ben bernanke is also involved in citadel
i mean you could name the list of
government officials that just go from
one day
public representatives of you to selling
you out the next day and it's absolutely
sickening what's going on here and guess
what
it's only going to get a lot worse this
is i
i was left dumbfounded this morning but
this is a good sign though
but this is this is how they're
panicking the veil was shattered exactly
this is a great sign because look how
desperate they're becoming that they're
literally you know going at the straws
you're being like
silver silver now i personally like
silver i i even made a video
two weeks ago saying hey i even
interviewed someone in the silver
business and i was like i personally
like silver as an alternative to the
dollar
not financial advice uh just my own
personal opinion
but even now when you look at the top
reddit post and you look at
what people are saying they're saying
wait wait wait there is no short on
silver
a lot of hedge funds do own silver as
well and they make
good good points there that really are
worth considering well here's here's the
interesting thing
uh well actually before i can let me say
this silver's fantastic
silver's great i love silver just not
when it's being pumped and dumped
when when all the media is claiming fake
something fake is happening like
all these redditors are telling you to
buy silver they're not
the price of silver skyrockets you buy
in when when silver is at 30
and then you're all excited and then the
hedge funds who are seeking to offset
their losses
sell out huge portions of silver at a
market at a premium
from your money then when silver tanks
the regular people panic not
understanding the market losing all of
that money
and then wall street absorbs it all buys
back the silver they gave out in the
first place
and makes that money they make money on
top and they get their silver back at
the same time
that's the game that's the manipulation
so how high you think they'll pump it
i don't know some people are posting
like it's going to hit 500 oh
maybe i've seen some interesting posts
where they say dude in reality
silver should be way higher yeah you
were saying they artificially keep the
price low so that you know
that's what they're saying online
they're saying that these companies
you know like if people if silver
tracked with inflation exactly higher
yeah
it's been like 16 bucks for a decade for
decades
here's the really interesting and
important thing about what's going on is
that they're not telling people to buy
physical silver
they're telling them to buy slv that's
where it's at which is that's
i think that's silver futures i'm not
entirely sure please no buy actual
silver i'm not an investment strategist
but
buying stock in something is very you
know ian is a is a crazy hippie guy in
the internet don't listen to
it on your third eye him what i do with
my gold don't you drink it like you put
in your drinks
yeah it's anti-microbial antibiotics put
in their clothes you ever see the silver
clothing
it's great no but i hear it's great for
you that's why there was always the the
term
born with a silver spoon in his mouth
your teeth
a lot of people believe that silver you
know has antibacterial antiviral
properties you can rub it in wood
and it kills werewolves yeah and it
kills werewolves that's the most
important part
so here's the rabbit dogs i i heard a
lot of people saying
they're trying to get people to buy slv
and not physical silver but if everyone
tried buying physical silver it would
seriously squeeze out
all of the all of the the actual
physical bullion stores and everything
which could actually have a serious
impact
apparently the banks won't be able to
cover if people actually want it so i
don't look i'm not gonna pretend to be a
stock guy
i'm just gonna tell you this i'm a media
guy i know how the media lies i know the
games they play
so don't get advice from me i want you
to with stock for me
this is about the overlap between the
the wall street bets readers and what
they're actually saying
and me being a critic of the media and
ex and trying to expose them in their
manipulation
and now seeing how you got a bunch of
the little it's the little guy
this dude deep effing value who's now
become a multi-millionaire off of his
you know his bets
he's just some dad in like the
massachusetts area he is not the machine
but now he's in the top point what is he
point one percent now
net worth is like 30 something million
dollars
dude there are ceos who who don't make
that much money in a year and he's made
it in six months doing what
what did he how did he make it yeah
investing in gamestop wow that's right
because it was at like five bucks and
that's at 300. wow
very serious increase in all of your
money and he's posting
you know his yolo updates and it's like
20 million
percent 20 million dollars up thousands
of percent
they don't like that you're not allowed
to be in the club we talked about this
with bernie sanders a while back
how bernie sanders used to say the
millionaires and the billionaires in
this country
and then one day he stopped saying stop
saying the millionaires one day he
became a millionaire exactly he sold a
book
yup so the book became a millionaire and
now he doesn't say it anymore
and that's insane because you still can
not someone but also
also we've talked about this before i
think the millionaires really aren't the
problem maybe if you're like
998 million not dude even someone who
has 200 million 200 million
they can someone that's worth 2.3
million dollars isn't
right yeah so why bernie sanders dropped
that is beyond me but that's that's i
don't want to get off the tangent on
bernie just yet we have some stuff on
barney for later
the media is smearing him what i'm
saying is bernie was standing outside
that mansion the clubhouse with
all the elites and all the re the
wealthy you know people
and he was outside and he was like oh i
want to be inside there with the
millionaires and the billionaires oh the
millionaires and the billionaires are
awful
screw them it was sour grapes you can't
beat them join them but then one day
they open the door and they say bernie
come on in you can be one of us and now
he stopped saying the millionaires
because they let him in the club this
dude deep effing value on wall street
bets is not part of the club
and so now he's somehow found his way
inside this building and they're pissed
off
they're looking over they're all wearing
their fancy suits pinkies out with their
and their monocles and they see this
dude with a red bandana on
who sell who bought a bunch of game stop
stock and it reminds me of like i played
a poker game once
and i literally had no idea what i was
doing because this is when i was like
18.
and i hell i i i kept i kept uh betting
more
and i was holding two seven off suit and
i ended up winning
because the last dude folded and he was
really angry
and then i showed what i had and he
started screaming and yelling what you
shouldn't have hold they should have
folded i should have won
and i was like i played better i guess
no it was just dumb luck i had no idea i
had the worst possible hand
and so now you have these people who are
in the club who have who have
sold their souls who have dropped to
their knees and given everything to be
in that club and this dude walks in
with this bandana on and he's like i
don't know i just bought a stock that
was probably not supposed to go up and i
screwed the hedge fund it's like that
eddie murphy movie from the 80s what was
it called
trading places was that what it was yeah
trading places i think where he became
the rich guy yeah i like it
yeah yeah so they they they give the the
bunk information to the
these big investors and then screw them
over he and dan aykroyd is it that they
switch yeah
murphy and danica oh great dan aykroyd
is this like a rich wall street trader
and he's like snooty
and eddie murphy's a homeless guy and
they make a bet and they switch them to
see if they can like
make it work or whatever it's a great
movie by the way time to watch that
movie i definitely want to watch it but
that's
that's a really fun movie people are
posting that like as a like me yeah
yeah yeah that's why it was on my mind i
guess yeah uh did
max kaiser just a few years ago call for
buying silver to squeeze out jp morgan
he's he's he's saying he's saying i
think max is tweeting now to do it
yeah i'm looking at what max is doing
now i'm gonna look at his twitter
account just to see because he he's also
a big silver guy
he's a big alternatives guy to the us
dollar so it'll be interesting to see
what he says i remember
uh seeing a lot of silver news with him
just a few years ago about this
specifically
listen listen i i like max he's a very
smart guy
but he's also he's a he's a crypto guy
he's a bitcoin guy
and i wonder if his perspective on it is
what they're doing the hedge funds won't
break the system it'll break the hedge
funds
and crypto will break the system so
that's why he's you know telling
everybody
you got to go after crypto short the
whole you know short squeeze the whole
system
but i will say you know maybe max is
right far be it for me to criticize that
guy that you know for those aren't
familiar max kaiser is he's been in the
game
for longer than i've been alive and
there was a funny video he posted from
like 1987 of him ragging on yuppies and
i'm like dude i
was pr i wasn't i was like one so uh
respect respect
to max what i can say is the redditors
are saying here's our mission and so
what we're seeing now with all of this
it's this is very similar what happens
with any semi-decentralized mass
movement
we saw with occupy wall street the first
one a lot of people were like yo we're
met at the banks and then also a bunch
of people came up and started screaming
about non-related unrelated issues
i remember i was not at occupy wall
street and they were having a meeting
over what their main demand should be
well everybody was there because the big
bank bailouts
and the the the gambling they did that
destroyed the market destroyed
everyone's livelihood
and i remember one one day while they're
having this meeting with like a ton of
people
some guy just like old white dude
randomly stood up and screamed
what is wrong with you people fracking
is the problem it's the center of
everything and i'm like what does
fracking have to do with the banks
but in his mind everything because he
couldn't see
past his own desire and demands so now
you're seeing a lot of people posting
now is our chance everybody buy dogecoin
why so they can get get rich off
dogecoin buying those credit doesn't
hurt anybody
and what happens is when the price of
dogecoin collapses because there's no
demand or interest
then people get left holding an empty
bag but what they're doing with with
gamestop
and amc and bed bath and beyond and
american airlines
these were the short targets so now
these hedge funds are going to lose
money what they're doing has an impact
but a bunch of people saw that power
they saw all of these people
shining their lights in a single
direction creating a massive you know
effect
and they said if only i could point that
in the direction i want i could have
more power
so everyone's trying to now wield the
power of wall street bets for themselves
we're seeing twitter accounts pop up
with the image claiming like
they're part of the movement or speak
you know in some way
we're seeing different reddits pop up
saying very similar things but there is
an overall unity for the most part like
there's a majority or
a majority of people saying gamestop amc
those are the targets yeah well the
movement's biggest strength is also its
biggest weakness because it is
decentralized you don't
really see a big rallying call you do
see a lot of censorship you do see a lot
of obfuscation by the mainstream media
but it's also a bunch of people being
like hey and a bunch of noise so it's
very hard to kind of organize that into
one big vocal
uh kind of representation here so it
could be just disorganized chaos that
happened organically or it could be
pushed on and spurred on by some other
elites who of course are benefiting off
of people being fractured and divided
and conquered
both are possible here but to me the
clear winner today
is definitely popeyes yes
popeyes with their attendees for all
campaign
with literally providing promo codes uh
for everyone
based off the stocks of the redditors um
you know obviously you know going into
the popular will
obviously tuning into this kind of new
movement
and uh trying to of course profit off of
it by selling uh probably uh
most likely gmo chicken i'm i'm down
tell me about this
so so popeye's put up a commercial that
said attendees aren't just for the wall
street elites attendees are for everyone
because the meme is that when you do
really really well
and like on your stock and you get a
profit it's you you're getting your
attendees or whatever
okay so they were like attendees for
everybody so
so now there's a promo code where if you
spend i guess i guess here we are
promoting popeyes oh look at that all
right you see the game you see
popeyes they did it it worked it's
something like if you spend five bucks
you get free free chicken tenders
oh i i if you spend five bucks on if you
order
online you use the promo code of the gme
stocks and you get a special discount or
something yeah
so if you if you do like dollar sign gme
dollars oh wow they bought it so they're
using the
movement as well wow good good good i
love this you know why
because regular people will see this and
and not know what it is right
if we get more corporate marketing to
embrace the idea
that there's money to be made from
people who are excited and happy about
this
then they're going to get more people
rallying and coming in
and and investing those stocks so like
if people signed up on timcast.com with
the special promo code there's no
special
there aren't those promo codes
dude if if corporate marketing gets
behind this
then you see real influential power
being like we're hipping
with it yes but hey sure fellow kids
yeah i'm waiting on amazon to go full
awakened
no look out there start accepting are
you kidding me
like yeah yeah that's like a very naive
amazon owns twitch
and that's like uh the the streamer
destiny who's a leftist
got stripped from the partner program
because he defended kyle rittenhouse
that's so crazy
that's that's amazon they own the
washington post who said the hedge fund
who said the hedge funds are the good
guys yeah i got like they also said guns
are white supremacy
and that maybe you shouldn't need two
thousand dollars like that's
literally some of the arguments that
they're making right right now it's
simple it's never been more clear
if you're trying to figure out what's
really going on and what you should
support
if the media is saying it assume the
opposite you guys ever see the episode
of seinfeld
where george decides to he's such a
failure just one day decides i'll do
literally the opposite of whatever i do
and then everything works out for him
that's a great episode by the way that's
how i feel with the media if the
mainstream media is coming out and
saying one thing
assume it's just the opposite it's sunny
today it must be raining well that can
get confusing because you you are the
this is media as well so some like and
this is corporate media timkes is a
corporation
oh come on it is technically corporate
media sure sure
qualify as a small business but it's
corporate media
oddly enough um so nah there's a lot
is it that it's like there's the
billionaire class yeah and then there's
you know private enterprise
this is a private enterprise amazon is
the billionaire class that exploited and
used and manipulated government for
their own personal benefit
that's a whole different case like
tesla's the billionaire class
they're getting a lot of government
contracts as well listen listen
there are still remnants of good old
capitalism alive and well today in this
country
that people who work hard and provide a
good service
will find themselves doing well in
expanding their business and having a
large platform
cnn are liars they cheat they steal they
manipulate
they're propped up by being put in
hotels and airports all over
all over the country and the world it's
not organic when they get their ratings
now they're they're they're ending cnn
airport but it's all
just it's it's pumped look at look at
you look how youtube you talk about
corporate media
youtube puts cnn and cbs and nbc on the
front
page i have to just we get suppressed
slack it out
so here's here's what i'm telling people
right now we have this interesting
non-partisan mass effort
where everyone can see the media is
lying but
listen capitalists you know like people
who are not into socialism socialism
look at what's happening with the
corruption and the command economy
how these elites can control socialism
for for me but not for the essentially
they say see that socialism when the
powerful elites steal the resources and
keep it for themselves
socialists are saying that's capitalism
that through the through their
monopolistic power
they collude and just stop poor people
from being able to get access to any of
the resources
and i'm just like yo that's just
corruption
capitalism is cap losses fair capitalism
and capitalism can be utopian
when we believe in this beautiful world
of free trade socialism can be utopian
my personal opinion a little bit of both
you know a little mixed economy here you
need some social programs but you got to
have a good regular you got to have a
good system
that can weed out failing programs and
improve them and you need market
competition and the ability of
individuals to work and trade as they
see fit
right now it's the wrong conversation
because we should be all in agreement
whatever you want to call it there's a
group of extremely powerful elites
who are stripping away the resources and
value from working class people
you want to call that socialism fine you
want to call capitalism i don't care
can we just arrest some people can we
just get some rallying behind the
manipulation
can we call out this this purposefully
circuitous system that makes it so hard
to track when you're trying to figure
out how any of this stuff works and
you're like i don't know how these
companies are
so no one knows what the fed is no one
knows how the federal reserve works sad
and true man
a lot of people know much about it and i
don't even know much about it as much as
i'd like to i want to have an expert on
here
well i think david i could work on that
david porting or i think said it best
jail
that's it stitch yeah so what
the former head of the sec made comments
very favorable towards the hedge fund
very against these reddit traders
elizabeth warren defended the hedge
funds i saw that yeah
who go who who does the arrest then who
does the investigation the justice
department no no no it's the local
sheriff who will come and arrest you ian
for daring to speak up against them but
who's going to go after the dtcc nobody
for extorting games or for extorting
robin hood no
no no one's going to go after them
you're the rebel they come for you
not the rebels no one's going to arrest
these people people always
naively think that the law applies to
everyone it doesn't when you're super
rich
you live by a whole different standard
of laws and rules that don't apply to
you that apply to everyone that's
always the case yes no no no no no it's
not the super rich it's the club
because look at that lawyer there was
that the fbi lawyer
who fabricated the establishment the
elite you correcting me i agree with you
look at uh jack ma
that's another great example of uh the
club with money
and then yeah yeah is he resurfaced yet
look they're investigating they're
investigating elon musk now
yes they're going after him because he
allegedly didn't hire enough non-us
citizens
i think that's the story yeah lydia can
you look that up
uh elon musk investigated for hiring
non-us
citizens which is a little bit
mind-boggling but i think in the justice
department you have a man either
everything that you need to hire non-us
citizens
either way the issue is elon musk may be
i think the second richest guy on the
planet
they will come after him that's the art
i do not like it you found it he's not
in the club
but the reality is the club has fallen
apart yeah and i think it says it in the
second byline there
the doj's immigrant and employee rights
section said it received a complaint
of employment discrimination from a
non-us citizen in may
and said spacex refused to comply with a
subpoena for relevant documents related
to hiring my mind is blown
yeah well there you go i know that he's
probably harsh about who he hires
the u.s department of justice
investigating spacex over whether the
company discriminates against
non-us citizens in its hiring according
to court documents filed on thursday
that's insane wow what that is crazy i
remember reading that a couple days ago
and reporting on my channel i'm like
wait wait wait wait they're going after
him for
that you can't discriminate again that
listen we're america we're not
look look you know they don't have
social security numbers no i don't know
isn't it isn't it painfully obvious
right now what's happening the club
let's okay so we talked about something
a while ago about i think this last week
i was talking about hillary clinton
losing
and i was like i always thought the game
was rigged you know i was just like
what's the point of voting and then
donald trump won and i was like huh
i guess you really can get your
candidate to win that restored my faith
in the system
all right but then i wondered how is it
that he won like
certainly the establishment elites who
manipulate media
and manipulate the markets could have
wrangled up enough effort
to to win and i'm not talking about
fraud or cheating i'm talking about
you know mail-in voting systems about
changing laws about
you know um running stories like what
they're doing right now about silver
just blatant just wrong stories over
manipulation
and it's because they didn't they
underestimated the internet and the meme
magic no joke
trump was memed into the president they
overestimated hillary clinton definitely
yeah yep and so then i started to think
maybe the the establishment elites who
normally have a have an
airtight control over the media and the
narrative and the system
are slipping they're losing their grip
now you look at what's going on with
gamestop
the game stocks and it's like they're
losing their grip
the hedge funds are are bleeding out
cash now you look at how the media
responded
with this what looks to be a coordinated
smear campaign to trick regular
americans
into buying up this uh slv losing money
but we can see right through it now it's
almost like you know the wizard of oz
and they pulled the curtain back and we
can see the man behind the curtain
he's still going just close my eyes and
they won't see me right
when i was on the show one of the first
times you were like what do we do what's
the solution i'm like memes and you're
like what do you mean means what are you
talking about
and i'm like dude you don't get it man
there's a whole culture that even
popeyes is picking up on
and the memes are literally the ones
that are waking people up and are more
effective
than a lot of the mainstream media
propaganda the cathedral is terrified of
memes i think ever since trump was
elected i think watching this gamestop
stuff is really making it worse
yeah there's a lot of even uh documents
that are uncovered and i have to refresh
myself and i don't want to speak out of
hand here
and i and i think that was referred to
your water to uh
to special operations talking about meme
warfare
that was released by edward snowden i
have to double check but
there's this is something that of course
government agencies see as a massive
threat
and i i think that i think the memes i
mean they're they're viral right now
i'm i'm tweeting and i'm instagramming a
whole bunch of them all the time because
just in that one simple image in that
simple representation you're able to get
across
ideas so much more effectively than any
video than any photo than any article
than any other kind of media form
and it's really its own form and and the
shares and the clicks and the way that
this spreads
is just exactly how this whole reddit
movement started
and exactly how it it has a momentum and
has an energy
and and when you look at even you know
the epstein situation no one even knew
about it until the memes
started coming out and that hashtag
started coming out so so this is
key and essential and and looking at the
memes now things are
looking in favor of the rhetoric there's
something really interesting jon stewart
i guess joined twitter recently yeah and
he tweeted
cheering on the the redditors he he
joined twitter did i say read it he
joined twitter and started cheering
you said twitter okay now he's cheering
on their editors and game style saying
good kick it to wall street you know
take them for what they're worth jimmy
kimmel so i couldn't find this tweet i
don't know if jimmy kimmel deleted it
but a bunch of people were sharing it
it apparently he said real donald trump
is this you or something like that
that you do and he is obsessed well no
no someone made a really good point
jon stewart is an old-school liberal who
has been
out of the game for several years he's
probably been minding his own business
for the most part
not realizing the sh the realignment
that's occurred jimmy kimmel is
realignment left
so he's a mock he's mocking uh jon
stewart
jon stewart comes out and says the right
thing is a leftist and he gets he gets
accused of being trump
and you look at what cnn said trumpism
explains
what's going on with with cnn jimmy
kimmel has has lost
i mean this is maybe i'm just preaching
the choir this is obvious but he is
completely
gone well if you if you look on i mean
he's done i was going to say something
kind of offensive you know that term off
the native american
but that's yeah yeah the whole phrase
off the reservation is a very racist
phrase i've come to learn but i don't
know it just means something about a
native american leaving
and then it's like that makes them crazy
or something like that i don't know
well also back to jimmy kimmel here i
mean when you look at him
you look at his eyes he looks beaten wow
he looks defeated he looks like
i you know i don't want to kind of
expound on here but but
he looks like he's not there he looks
like he's just absolutely miserable
doing his job
yes look look when i see a lot of these
people in media
colbert and kimmel and these like late
night hosts
there's no passion they don't care it's
like
dude give me the script and i'll read it
okay so uh russian bots are buying stock
and uh what's that line redditor what is
and i would advise everyone to go watch
this kimmel talked it's 30 seconds long
and he
and he mentions that the redditors might
be russian assets
did he write that or did his writers
write that and hand it to him and he
just went with it it's the cathedral man
it's disgusting what does russia have
anything to do with these russian people
with these russian people it starts with
an arm
there's alliteration involved well
bloomberg even went on to describe
people a part of this larger movement as
insurrectionist
so did the former sec chairman
so we have to understand this is
aggressive language that we're seeing
towards
poor people playing the market and
outsmarting the people who used to play
the market the hedge funds this reminds
me of
occupy wall street because at occupy
wall street the banks began
to rupture you could see their terror um
the whole industry was like
you know what the jig is up it's we're
done for let's save as many of our necks
as we can because they're
it's over just really quick i want to
make a point here what made occupy wall
street prominent because it was ignored
for a very long time was a
disproportionate
response by the state they were
extremely aggressive and they hit
back very hard and there was one pepper
spray incident that really went viral
that started everything tony bologna
tony bologna
exactly and it was literally
overreaction by the state we're seeing
another
overreaction by the authorities by the
establishment right now as we're
speaking with this absurdity that some
people are calling news
let me let me tell you luke democracy
dies in darkness did you know this
ah i heard the washington post from
which is the bezos times
in their in their op-ed about the hedge
funds being the good guys
let me read a passage for you they said
this time is different
the gamestop speculators are not merely
in a frenzy about one stock
their goal is to destroy the traders who
link stock prices to
fair value to suggest a political
analogy
they are not just blindly devoted to
their candidate they deny the legitimacy
of the opposition party
they are not just acting within the
system they want to
overthrow the system it says though just
imagine
a rabble gripped by conspiracy theories
were to attack the rules of democracy
itself
the name gamestop is apt do you know
what that passage is saying
they're saying the redditors are the
same thing as trump supporters
and the action they're taking is the
same as the insurrection is is the
they're calling it you know essentially
the insurrection attacking democracy
itself the storming of the case i wrote
that by the way
uh he oh you're like this luke this is
sebastian
maliby he's the paul a volcker senior
fellow for international economics the
council on foreign relations ah
okay makes perfect sense yes i know this
you know we have barely they kicked me
out of there permanently and banned me
you were walking around with volcker
yes i had a very interesting
conversation mr paul volcker you could
look it up on we
are change he was actually very nice but
he was lost so i was literally telling
him where to go into a secret vip room
that he accidentally took me into
whoopsie because security goes like oh
he's clearly with him and then that's
when he brought me to ben bernanke
another individual who by the way
is also a senior advisor at citadel
which people should know
and is also the former chairman of the
u.s federal reserve and citadel owns
stock the silver stock that's you said
that's like 50 of their
they own i guess they own slv look i'm
i'm just basically going off of what
wall street bets has been saying about
what's going on so you went to the cfr
i kind of want to touch on this oh yeah
a number of times where they had press
events and
and it was actually this is a wild story
too
it was eric schmidt's girlfriend who
kicked me out
of the cfr permanently because i was
always coming in there
and then they kicked me out and they
denied me press credentials so i had an
alias
that i went under i got in there again
then they kicked me out then i had a
third alias
then say your alias i don't i don't want
to say it i don't think
well one of them i'll release one of
them one of them is public
and his name was bill yes and last name
de berg
so when you read that together
mr bill here let him in because i did
the accreditation i had the credentials
they let me into the council on foreign
relations and they had press conferences
and i stood up asked my question like
everyone else but the difference was i
wasn't
kissing but i wasn't throwing softballs
i went right for the gullet verbally
with hardcore legitimate reasonable
questions
that should have been asked about
corruption and all these horrible things
that these people do in secret
that was finally exposed with this
questioning they hated it kicked me out
three times
and the fourth time eric schmidt's
girlfriend because i looked
who this was gave me a call personally
she's like luke we know who you are
just stop it you're banned you're not
coming in
we're doing this because you're gonna be
arrested if you step foot into the cfr i
don't care how many aliases i don't care
how many disguises you have you're not
coming in
and i'm like ladies ladies and gentlemen
i waited outside by the way
who's eric schmidt again eric schmidt is
the former
chairman of alphabet the former head of
google who
also is working with the government
especially the pentagon on their
technological advancements
in the military now that you've
mentioned eric schmidt is formerly the
head of uh google
if you were wondering why you might get
banned in the future
my channel was kicked out of the partner
program i think very unfairly
i mean if i mean did you ever find out
why
no oh come on no he he he you ambushed
eric schmidt
i did an ambush i asked him a question
ambush journalism is just a reference to
you seeing him walking and going up and
asking him questions
i politely asked him about financing and
fundraising a lot of the tink thanks
uh that were thanks sorry good enough
you know what i'm saying here think
tanks think tanks that were organizing
the term
fake news because the term fake news
kind of came out of nowhere
nowhere and it was galvanized as a way
pushed by hillary clinton to go against
donald trump to go against independent
media
and it all started according to a lot of
investigative journalism from
a lot of the groups that were financed
directly by him and google
so i went up to him and i was like hey
eric schmidt let's talk about you
working with hillary clinton on her
campaign let's talk about you donating
to her and you helping her create some
of the biggest buzzwords that the media
is using right now and weaponizing right
now
to destroy free speech and then he
looked you in the eyes and listen to
your little piss ant
i'm going to strip your youtube channel
from the partner program
he was like this is effing absurd uh
you're effing crazy i'm like sir please
stop cursing you're gonna get my youtube
video demonetized
and obviously i knew that you know what
but that's not the first time we got him
uh we also got him at another bilderberg
in switzerland this is all of course as
he's going to the bilderberg
group meeting which the mainstream media
by and large chooses not to report on
even though it's 150 of the most
influential people coming together
in secret let's let's wait hit that
point
how do these all factor and there's
bilderberg davos and the council on
foreign relations there's also the
trilateral commission and there's groups
within groups within groups and
affiliations within all these different
groups and i could talk about this for
hours but one last thing before we segue
i kind of really wanted to bring up some
of the amazing positive stories we
should focus on some of those here
and those are of individuals who
enriched themselves through this whole
gamestop saga
and they're doing incredible things the
new york post has an article right now
that is titled
college student donates gamestop gains
to buy video games for sick kids
and there's a large number of these
individuals actually going out of their
way
taking profit and doing really like
amazing things that are
that are helping people you look at the
hedge funds that money yeah that's hedge
fund money yeah
exactly that what did headphones do the
the the ceo
of of malvin capital is still moving
forward
with literally destroying and bulldozing
a house next to his
so he could build the tennis court
that's what melvin capital is
this kid he's making sure sick kids get
video games
he's making sure people get helped in
their communities and you see tons of
these stories there was another post on
reddit
that said this is for my father um
that was absolutely a tear-jerker that
that talked about a lot of the bigger
things about a lot of the bigger reasons
a lot of the
motive behind this which is absolutely
important to know the story was that his
dad's
construction company i believe
construction was destroyed
by the housing market crisis caused by
these big banks
and that since that needs to become like
basically a destitute alcoholic who's
lost the will to live yeah and so he's
like this is for you dad this is this is
you know
the the the sun has come back for
vengeance against those but this is
important a lot of these reddit kids
saw their families devastated especially
in 2008
they were kicked out of their homes in
the in the housing market crisis
last year they had their private
businesses enterprises shut down by the
lockdowns and here they are
saying we're going to come together and
we're going to play by the rules and
we're going to work the market towards
the benefit of
everyone we're going to literally be
robin hood
in the modern day and age and what
happens the system conspires
colludes against them calls them
insurrectionists calls them losers
says they're connected to russia says
that they're going to be cutting
themselves and
and and harming themselves are you
kidding me because they made a little
bit of money that they're actually
spreading around
to the economy that is sick and
disgusting bastardization of news
and people's responsibility if you're a
journalist right now and you're not
reporting on this fairly and honestly
you are not a journalist you're a
propaganda mouthpiece for the
establishment elite and you have no
soul within yourself and i am sick of
these people they know it yeah and they
don't care
like when i saw that bloomberg that clip
from wall street about
about the bloomberg saying redditors
lose interest i'm like what are you
talking about it's the number one
post right now on reddit telling people
to buy more stock one dude
just announced who's putting a million
dollars into gamestop
a million bucks right now is not going
down they are
lying these are not journalists they
know they're propagandists for the state
and they know what they're doing for the
longest time i've given many of them
the benefit of the doubt but each and
every one of these who was writing an
article saying buy silver
predators want you to buy silver they
know they are lying
or they're just useful idiots who are
too stupid to do their job
one thing's for sure they're not
journalists but but listen listen
we we're this is a good segue because my
friends why is it
that washington dc is putting up these
permanent barricades now in the green
zone you hear about this
yeah you know the barricades all around
dc yeah yeah it's permanent
okay when did this decide when they
decided to make this last minute okay
and they're going to leave 5 000
national guardsmen there i've heard of
this you know why
there is a real threat there is they
keep saying there's like a threat of
white supremacy in the far right
it's not really that i mean they'll say
that but there is a threat
the real threat is the rebel who can see
the shed
they can see now through the shattered
veil it's almost like the matrix
and then one day all these robots are
tending to the human crop and then a
bunch of humans wake up
and they can see what's going on around
them and if the machine doesn't get a
hold of things those people are gonna
get real
angry and they're gonna rise up so we
see this massive security effort in dc
now we see the next and most interesting
iteration
in the desperation of the state because
they're really scared about what happens
when people realize
not only is the game rigged but we are
stealing everything from you and your
family and we're laughing the whole way
down
a new gun bill would require public
registry of all weapons this is
hr127 this is
one of the most insane things i've ever
read to the point where i really don't
think it will pass
but this is a new gun control measure
it's been proposed by uh jackson lee
sheila a democrat from texas and it's
gonna it requires a lot of things i
don't know if you have a lot of the
the points on the gun control bill i do
that you want to bring up specifically i
want to bring up
more about that security theater you
were bringing up because there's a cnn
legal analyst named elliot williams who
tweeted
quote seems like a good day for a
reminder that in any other year hundreds
of giddy children from across washington
dc
would be sledding at the capitol
building all day long
they can't because the grounds are
closed to the public following a
domestic terrorist attack
and then i mean just the hyperbolic just
the fear-mongering just the nonsense
there and i think michael tracy had a
response that is worth noting here and
commenting on
and he said or alternatively the
children can't sled on the hill
because a security theater panic has
been ginned up
and virtually no one in a position of
influence has bothered even questioning
it
and i think he's wrong why it's not
security theater
it could be no uh no no no i'll tell you
it's that the media right now
their lies are so obvious luke you were
telling me about the kill dozer
yes i watched a documentary about the
killdozer and
my goodness gracious uh that was the
gist of the killdozer story
it was an individual who felt wronged by
city council and he decided
to take out his feelings of of being
mistreated by the government by
literally building huge slabs of steel
surrounding the giant bulldozer which he
put in a 50 caliber
firearm that was shooting out of and
other rifles out of through little ports
and went on
a rampage in a small town literally
going after anyone who
thought he was wrong by him they
couldn't stop him
it's called the kill dozer and he only
got stopped because his kill dozer fell
into a basement
when he was just he like destroyed a
city councilman's house or whatever
well he was going after one of the
businesses that was owned by one of the
people that okay okay that was wrong
it's not security theater now the media
is lying about in my opinion i think the
me is aligned with the threat the far
right
now i think the real threat is that the
veil has been
shattered they know it they know we can
now see them all working the machines
behind the scenes going uh-oh
what do we do now if you have one person
who feels wronged by the government in
that way
and this one person goes nuts and builds
a killdozer i mean this is freaky stuff
we don't want this stuff we don't want
this this this no no we need to do
everything in our power to prevent
violence but you probably
as much as we can by having justice but
these these these crony machines
the crony machine doesn't want that
instead they're now putting up massive
barricades around the capitol
so that so they're like we know what's
coming
we know the rage is there and they don't
care if it's
look the media will tell you one thing
but that's the point i bring up that's
why i bring up
this new firearms yeah restriction like
the restrictions hr127
they want you to have a license and
insurance and a whole bunch of crazy
things listen the craziest thing about
it is that
there are a lot of people right now who
have a bunch of guns they would want you
to pay
pay fees get liability insurance they
would want you to register each and
every weapon
mandatory psych evaluations are a
national
gun owner license gun insurance for
everything
as well as a publicly accessible
database
and they want to ban 50 bmgs i mean
are are you kidding me i mean this is
absolutely draconian
this is frightening this is terrifying
because you know there's going to be a
lot of individuals who are not going to
register their firearms
and this this this you know house
resolution makes it so you have to
or you face penalties and fines that
could land you in jail for
a year to 40 years look at this let me
read you from this article i have this
is from the daily fly they say
a pro-gun group called the citizens
committee for the right to keep and bear
arms called the bill insanity on
steroids they say over the years we've
seen some astonishingly bad legislation
originate on capitol hill
but this one takes the term abomination
to an entirely new level
one look at this bill and you wonder
whether congresswoman jackson lee ever
heard of the bill of rights
which includes the second amendment the
bill would also ban all
50 caliber weapons all 50 counts not
just bmg
all 50 cal now my friends a couple of
years ago i talked about i was like oh
why
maybe you have liability insurance or
you know a license and someone responded
to me
that's great it's a really good idea tim
uh i'm totally in favor of getting you
insurance liability insurance for your
speech and you have to get a license to
be able to speak publicly
and then i was like wait wait no no i
don't want that like oh
i see your point the bill of rights says
these things
are in uh you know inalienable rights we
have the right to keep and bear arms we
have the right to speak and i said
okay that's that you're right i don't
want any restrictions on my speech for
the
you know for the most part except for
like committing a crime and it's already
illegal to commit a crime with a weapon
therefore all right you should keep all
the kids should be able to have a weapon
now they're doing everything in their
power to you know make these moves
we knew it was coming under joe biden
but this when i read this
like it's a whole insanity on steroids
is an understatement yeah
more importantly i don't think it will
pass because you're going to have
some you know more moderate democrats
especially like
i can't see bernie sanders agreeing with
this well there are so some pro-gun
democrats out there but we also have to
remember there has been a
huge surge of new gun owners
a lot of them from cities a lot of them
from democratic areas
that are understanding that hey you know
maybe i shouldn't wait 15
20 30 minutes for a police to respond
maybe it'll be better if i have
something that i could
defend myself with just like all the
celebrities and politicians have
you know they have all these security
guards they have all these people always
protecting them with firearms
and and with this you know law with this
resolution that they're trying to get
past
hr 127 this is going to lead to massive
amount of harm this is going to lead to
a massive
amount of problems that's only going to
make the situation that much worse would
ban gun ownership for people under 21.
what it's not going to happen that's
that is it like you're in a you're a
legal adult at 18. you have
constitutional rights you can fight in
the military
yeah i mean we've all we've already seen
just how bad
the laws are and you know what you know
i was really i was i've been thinking a
lot more about this
as i now own a decent quantity of
firearms myself uh my opinion on 2a has
gone
super far into pro 2a whatever you want
to call it
the the second amendment says the right
to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed the right to bear
arms
shall not be infringed right yeah so
should i be able to walk around
bearing arms well depends on where
you're walking around but for the most
part where why what does that mean when
you're walking around my living room i
might have a say in it well that's
private property yeah there's nothing to
do with the gun
if look if someone breaks your house
with a gun it's a crime even if i
invited you over and you just
pulled out a gun and i didn't know you
had one yeah probably freak out yeah but
that's not a crime if you invite someone
your house the issue is
in many places in like the vast majority
of places
the government tells you can't bear arms
no lie
like legitimately i was at the post
office the other day and there was a
sign in the door saying it is a
violation
of federal law to have a firearm inside
you know post-ops or whatever and i was
like
how do they do that does the
constitution not exist
i'm sorry i'm not saying it's a good
thing to walk around with a gun
literally everywhere like
i'm not saying that someone should open
carry walking into a post office i'm
saying
isn't it weird the constitution says you
can't do it and they literally did
and that's it the constitution is beyond
swiss cheese it is tattered rags
so while i look at this and i'm thinking
it won't pass when you look at what
you know luke and other people are
calling security theater you look at the
rage people have
and the manipulation tactics are
starting to fail they are getting scared
to the point where i think they'll try
and ram this through
maybe but it's junk i mean you can't
there's so many
ghost guns now that have been 3d printed
and unregistered no one's going to
those people reality check are not going
to register their weapons and if you try
and pass a stupid bill like that
you're going to make a large segment of
the american people criminals
and then that will lead to civil unrest
at a level we haven't seen yet so don't
do it
well normally i'd say i wouldn't
necessarily agree because i think
the american people typically comply but
i read a story about red flag laws
there was this old guy and was
apparently like i don't know some like
ex-girlfriend or ex-wife
called the police saying he was unwell
and he was armed so the police came to
serve a red flag
warrant or whatever they call it that's
where they take your guns away they show
up at your house you've committed no
crime and they say
someone thinks you're unwell you have to
give us your guns and then wait
a period until you undergo an evaluation
and then you get your guns back and if
you fail then you'll get your guns back
so this guy he's an older guy's in his
60s i guess
here's a knock at the door and he grabs
his gun and he answers the door with the
gun and the cops tell him we're here to
take your guns and he says
like how you are and so they fight over
his gun and then they shot and killed
the guy
when people say my cold dead hands they
mean it right and
and god forbid a situation where the
cops go to serve something like that and
the cops get killed and then
the cops are like i'm not serving those
stupid red flag things anymore i'm not
putting myself there i'm not going into
someone's
house when they're armed and crazy to
take their weapon that's not my job let
me ask you luke
are you familiar with the phrase when
the government when the people fear
their government there's tyranny but
when the government fears their people
there's liberty
i think i heard about that one thomas
jefferson
was it i believe so i don't know um you
know i believe that was it
what what these barricades that are
being put up around dc are they for a
foreign threat
definitely not the government seems to
fear its people right now but i'm not
seeing a whole lot of liberty
yeah and also you know a lot of the
things that are
called upon with this house resolution
are absolutely nonsensical they don't
make any sense if you want to stop
gun violence you would deal with inner
cities where guns are banned
that's where most of the gun homicides
are at same with suicide same with
police officer shootings when you look
at the statistics
people having the ability to defend
themselves is not a bad
thing overall especially in the kind of
grander experiment in the united states
if you look at places that are more gun
friendly where you have more freedoms
to bear arms you have a lot less crime
you have a lot less
murders you have a lot less homicides
and i think that's because people
are are equalized by knowing that they
could defend themselves are you allowed
to open carry in
austin texas i don't know about austin
texas specifically they do have a very
left-leaning mayor and a lot of
transplants from california do move
there
gun laws are extremely spotty all over
the united states there's no universal
law
you know places in new hampshire you
could literally open carry anywhere and
everywhere you go
except for federal buildings but other
places like new york city they make you
jump through
impossible hoops just to get a firearm
for
personal home defense so again they vary
it all depends on the state and there's
so many different laws that ban one
thing in one state but it's totally
legal in another state
well i looked up austin texas.gov and it
says that
you can open carry in the state of texas
is there widespread
death mayhem and murder from people who
are legally owning guns
in the city in texas not that we've uh
seen
you know so i was i was looking at some
rural areas and
you know driving around places in west
virginia and wondering
you know i was thinking to myself it's
really funny there's like volunteer fire
department there's no real police
department it's like sheriffs
so so where's all the where's all the
gun violence from all these these gun
owners
in the inner cities it doesn't make deep
cities but but that's not true for
austin
like austin has opened texas is legit so
what's wrong with new york california
and chicago they're packed in
well people people don't no that's not i
mean people are sure if a criminal wants
a gun
or a weapon or to hurt someone they're
gonna find it one way or another in
europe they're using trucks they're
using buses they're using knives
and there's even conversations in the
united kingdom about banning knives and
they have in some jurisdictions dude
they arrested there was this big story a
couple years ago where they arrested a
construction worker for having i think a
leatherman and they're like it's a knife
sir
and he was like but the law exempts like
tools and they're like sir it's a knife
and so they confiscated and gave gave
him a fine or something like that
that's that's uh that's the uk dude i
i've seen i've seen stories about kids
in my neighborhood tying a shoelace to a
padlock and then swinging it and
whacking someone in the head with it so
they banned padlocks no joke
they were like padlocks are banned and i
was like why and they're like because
someone tied it to a shoelace and whacks
you could fill a sock with sand and
break someone's skull with it you don't
ban
sand yeah well sand sand man the beast
sand wouldn't work all that well you
have to do quarters
that's what they do they put they put
chains quarters would do it and then
they put in a sock and
forks make people fat we should ban
forks you could snap someone with a fork
you may want to be careful you may want
to consider
i'm not a joke about that no it really
is crazy to me that there's there's co
there's there's
serious cultural problems and guns
there's no correlation
i mean look people in new york have guns
and people will get shot
it's getting worse and worse and worse
it's up the ridiculous amount
percentage-wise
chicago right but why is it that in
places where guns are heavily
heavily restricted you have these
problems and in places where guns aren't
heavily restricted you kind of don't
have these problems um
pharmaceutical drugs okay banning these
tools won't make a difference because it
won't address the problems that
you know particular cities are dealing
with cultural problems
family problems father problems family
problems there's a lot of bigger issues
out there that if you really want to
prevent harm
you could actually do one of my favorite
things was
you know i saw an advertisement i
actually saw this on reddit too and it
was eat mcdonald's and right next to it
it was like social distance it's for
your safety it's like
you know you have these two larger
contradictory messages out there you
know in in this idea that the government
cares for you that we need a bigger
government to fix the the government's
problems that they created themselves
it's just
it's it's insane and and gun control i
mean it's a step
towards total tyranny because once they
go after that
i mean anything's on the table for what
they could do to you and we saw
governments in canada governments in
australia really
push it to the limit to what they could
do with their citizens
right after they got rid of their
ability to have uh
you know firearms and we saw huge
legislation canada australia
that that almost eliminated people's
abilities to defend themselves it's not
even
i i don't i think you know you're saying
banning the tool won't change anything
and i think even out in places like west
virginia
gun laws are it's totally cultural
everything we're seeing the crime the
problems culture problems
the the the lack of crime it also has
nothing to do with guns i don't think
the fact that someone can open carry
deters crime
i i'm thinking about how you can talk to
a sheriff and he's going to be like hey
man
you know i'm not going to go in and mess
with you and do these things you go to
new york and tony baloney pepper sprays
forward on the street for no reason
it's cultural problems in big cities
where people are nasty
and you know what i think it is a lot of
people say like oh it's the blue it's
the democrats and i'm like no no i think
i think culture and decay in blue cities
leads to corrupt politicians who use
feel-good democrat policies to gain
power
and then you look at these other cities
where they have open carrying things
like that
it's because they're more trusting of
each other it's like you want to open
carry sure i'm not worried about you i
don't think you're going to shoot me
right in new york they're like you can't
have that cause i'm worried you're going
to shoot me
in dc they put up big fences and a
security primer because they're scared
people are going to come after them it's
it's absolutely hypocritical to see
individuals like nancy pelosi
that that wants machine guns at the
capitol
telling you you can't have a firearm you
can't defend yourself you can't have a
weapon of war and we're seeing such
bastardized
language we're seeing such orwellian
tactics used here
to make you paint as some kind of crazy
terrorist criminal if you believe in the
right to defend yourself
no no you're just a logical thinking
human being that understands
just like as you keep saying to him it's
important to have a fire extinguisher in
your house
because again it's not that you're going
to of course look for fires
but but it's there in case there is one
and that preventative
prevents a lot of crime let's just be
honest here when we see
strong armed robberies they don't take
place where they have a lot of
individuals that are
that are armed they usually take place
in situations where people are disarmed
so so what's what's that movie with uh
gerard butler
and the guys break into his house and
like kill his family and it becomes like
this crazy revenge rampage
yeah i don't know the name of it what
was that was that movie called i forgot
i don't he's great i'm not a big movie
guy
so it's it's gerard butler and what is
this leonidas from 300.
let me let me see if i can look this up
did you watch it what happened in the
movie i haven't seen the movie just like
that it's a law-abiding citizen
so he's a work he's like he's a dad he's
got a wife and a kid
and then one day there's uh his doorbell
rings and he opens it and then he
immediately gets smacked in there with a
baseball bat and falls down
they zip tie his hands and then they
murder his wife and his daughter
later on when these guys get probation
or whatever or you know get off on good
behavior
he kidnaps and tortures them and then
publicly releases the evidence
purposefully want to go to prison and
then tries to get revenge on the system
i digress i'm not making a point about
that i thought it was a great movie i
wish
i think the ending was bad but you know
that it is what it is but i was thinking
about that
and i'm like based on this character's
willingness to like get revenge
you know he doesn't seem like gerard
butler's character does not seem like a
shy
man to say the least but i was thinking
about even having a firearm in your home
is no guarantee you'll be prepared for
when the threat really really comes yeah
which is why
being able to open carry is important
being able to have your weapon on you
and being comfortable confident and well
trained
because when you answer the door someone
might crack in with a baseball bat
i mean it's it's a movie i know but you
know i think about this
just working here and everything like
that and and wondering about what's the
point of even having a fire extinguisher
if it's too far away and a fire happens
you can't put it out right when chaos
ensues uh
things happen fast you've got to have
well so we put fire extinguishers in
like every room
like most businesses will do this all
the fire extinguishers in every room
okay well what happens if you see these
you know i love you see this commercial
there's a gun control commercial
where a guy angrily storms into an
office with a musket and then he fires
once and then he stops and he starts
loading it he pours the powder in and he
puts the ball and he starts stuffing it
and it's like uh-huh we get the point
and they were like this is what the
founding fathers expected
and i'm like how do you subdue a threat
when
kids can go into a school with any
weapon they want and go on a rampage
like how do you stop the threat you
gotta go to the root that's my thing i
don't know if you can
you can you can try and make less
threats that's probably the best way to
do it and i think the threats are
pharmaceutical drugs personally i
i think that a lot of inner city crime
comes from drugs or alcohol abuse
and desperation poverty that leads to
those kind of things it's easy to get a
40.
it's easy to that doesn't get get it out
so now you're blaming people for smoking
weed and drinking but when you look at a
lot of mass shootings
these kids are whacked out these humans
have like wide eyes
they look like they're on something i
would disagree with you saying if
someone gets high or drunk they go shoot
up places especially if they get i don't
think that's
true but but i think the point that
you're getting at is that a lot of mass
shooting events
were connected to individuals who were
on ssr notably yeah
yeah well so yes but the point i'm
saying is it's there's there's cultural
issues
in chicago a leading factor for these
shootings is
lovers trysts like i i went night
crawling
and a bunch of these deaths we were
tracking was a guy smack talking some
other guy on twitter about
or snapchat about some girl he was
hooking up with people think
it's gangs it's not so there is a
culture issue
we used to have duels we used to
actually have this i guess now
what they're doing is nothing to do with
honor it's just like the willingness to
kill someone who slights you
back in the day that at least give you
10 paces and then you turn right
what what's happening in chicago is a
guy will post on snapchat
like you know after your girlfriend the
guy says you're going to get it and then
the guy drives his house and shoots the
other guy
that's what's happening in chicago so
that's a cultural problem where
someone's willing to kill someone else
we just said this story
where some young girls stabbed another
girl to death just because like
they they were bragging about it on
social media that's another part that's
absolutely
that's that's why young children it has
nothing to do with guns i think guns are
a scapegoat for the deep-seated cultural
problems and the and the cultural decay
affecting this well humans have been
killing each other forever but what i'm
saying is if you go to austin and
everyone's open caring and you're not
having this extremely high murder rate
then what's going on in new york city
something is broken and has nothing to
do with guns
because there's no correlation between
the murder and guns
if you look at you know uh the city of
tehran
they are arming themselves illegally
because the mexican government tells
them to stop
uh arming themselves they told them to
give up their weapons
and their death rate in their town went
to zero percent
it was some of the highest debt death
rate in all of mexico
went to zero when the citizens started
to arm
themselves and literally kicked out the
government and the police and the
cartels all along in one smooth move
so we're having an individuals that are
armed that do have a lot of
firearms that are protected that have
their own militias that do open carry
throughout the streets
and you have zero murders when you had
hundreds of murders beforehand and the
highest death rate in all of mexico in
michoacan
one of the deadliest states of all of
mexico
so so that's another tale that i think
is worth noting worth talking about here
with this larger debate especially in
mexico where guns are illegal
but homicides by firearms are extremely
high maybe
you know that thomas jefferson quote
assuming it was jefferson it is
jefferson jefferson
got it right yeah maybe maybe the issue
is actually people should reasonably
respect
trust and fear each other yeah
reasonably yeah what i mean what i mean
by that is
i should you know look if you've got
some dude who's like six
six and like 220 just sheer muscle or
250 or whatever
and i don't know what what the right
muscle mass to like height would be
but like some super ripped jacks murphy
well
some super jack murphy dude yeah but
like super soldier
i don't know if jack murphy's a super
soldier he's just tall just think of
jack murphy while we're telling him no
i'm talking about like a
like a he-man type yeah and he walks
around knowing that he's bigger and
stronger than everyone and pushes him
around
now you have a five foot tall woman and
he's laughing at her mocking her
and then she's got on her on her waist
you know she's got a
revolver and so all of a sudden he's a
bit more respectful
it's it's people know like with with
being armed and being respectful
trustworthy but also
having something you know giving someone
reasonable fear of if they screw with
you they have something to fear
this this way you might have back in the
day some big tall guy who knows he's
stronger than you can push you around
now i've got everybody who's armed and
they're going to be like
i'm not worried about you shooting me
but i'm not going to screw with you
because i know you can
that works if people are not desperate
but
when people are civil but if people
become desperate they change they become
wild animals
well that's the point i was making about
the fences around the perimeter
of dc and the veil shattering of the
media narrative
and now this like huge gun ban and joe
biden's plan for like
you know taxes on firearms and magazines
and all this stuff because they're
seeing now that people can see what's
happening they can see the manipulation
their their jobs their lives were
destroyed they're becoming desperate
and we already saw what happened with
the kill dozer so they're like can we
ban the guns from all of these people
who are going to get really angry at us
yeah like i feel like we've got to just
give over to the fusion fusion power
and molecular printing and evol like
exploration and evolution we got to
colonize mars we're going to keep
expanding and growing as a society
because if we try and stop that
momentum it's good we're going to end up
stressing out and killing each other i
feel like that's what we've been doing
and it doesn't look like it's going to
change you see they want more defense
well historically
if you look at the largest killer of
people it's usually demicide
which is death by government so
historically
saying what the biggest threat here it's
usually typically
government you know we need people to
have confidence in the system and feel
comfortable and respected
and that's not happening you talk about
wanting to go to mars infusion energy
and all stuff and i completely agree
it's just really hard to do
when you have a manipulative sociopathic
establishment
that strips the value of all the working
people and allocates it to really
dumb things yeah people don't like
copper copper mining they're obsessed
with copper wiring because of all that
profit from the copper
if we if we started using wireless power
we wouldn't need the copper anymore
all those people would lose so much
money depending on who you ask i mean a
lot of conservatives are pointing out
that
that a lot of high profile investors
make money off the trains
transporting crude and the freight
transporting crude so they don't want
keystone pipeline
they they want to get rid of it so that
they can keep charging contracts for the
transportation of oil and things like
that oil that's another one
they don't they people love pumping
their oil the copper and the oil
um what else do they need there's
there's a lot of issues with the system
misappropriating things but when you
look at the amount
maybe very simple we have 10 million
dollars should we spend it on
i don't know covering the medical costs
for as many u.s citizens as possible
which it wouldn't be that many relative
to total population or
should we allocate it to pakistani
gender studies programs
that's my point the system is so broken
yes i'd love fusion yes i'd love to go
to mars
i want to do it what do we rely on elon
musk to get us there by 2026. he's
saying right the private sector is doing
it instead of the government because the
government's taking your money
and giving it away to foreign countries
and it's been happening our
infrastructure is crumbling been
hijacked by the federal reserve and
those dudes john rockefeller and his
buddies in the early 1900s
they wanted to establish a system that
couldn't screw them over again
rockefeller was pissed after he lost
standard oil i'm sorry let me let me
just let me just interject one thing
real quick
uh look i don't want people to feel like
there's no hope the fact that they're
talking about banning weapons and
building security
is irrelevant just for one reason the
game stop stuff is working
the the media narrative has been totally
blown out and we can see it now which
means
i'm really optimistic actually i'm a
huge leader i think what we're seeing
now is the old guard has lost
their ability the establishment has lost
control and the people are taking the
power back
and i wasn't so confident you know
earlier in the year but seeing wall
street vets
challenge these hedge funds and win
seeing how desperate the media has
become and then seeing
that they've become so desperate they
are revealing themselves
i'm like wow they're done they're done
they're not going to be able to carry
out these lies anymore
the wall street bets thing is
non-partisan everybody's mad at wall
street for what they did
and for what they're doing and the
media's desperate attempts to shield
them
won't work because people can just open
their phone and see they're lying kind
of like
as the water boiled the first bubble
that popped up was occupy wall street
after the collapse in 2008 like it
really started to appear after 2007 with
internet video and we could read all the
all the code finally we could see the
inner workings and then that was the
first bubble that rised up and it popped
and they kind of
glazed over but now another bubble is
rising identity politics bro
yeah they try to exactly no it's not
boiling see there's no bubbles on the
surface right now so it's not boiling
there's another bubble coming
after 2008 the terms whiteness systemic
racism
intersectionality white supremacy
discrimination all of them skyrocketed
right after
occupy wall street because when they saw
the class war coming
they said make it an identity war and
now it's like a russian thing they're
trying to make it a nationalist oh yeah
yeah meanwhile wage salaries all of them
when you adjust them for inflation
dramatically going down people are
getting screwed over more than ever
wealth between the rich and the poor is
widening like
never before especially from last year
when the stock markets
and all the hedge funds and all the big
banksters were making money hand over
fist while everyone was suffering dude i
i'm gonna say this i was right i said
the best thing for democrats would be
for trump to win
because it allows them to keep control
of the populist left
once trump is out and the left says okay
we hate biden too what are they gonna do
now you've got all the trump supporters
who hate biden and the progressives left
who hates biden
and now all of that populist energy is
pointed at the establishment
step one wall street bets and you've got
the donald trump
form patriots not win formerly donald
cheering this on
and then you've got socialists and
tankies far right far left up down
whatever you want to call it they're all
laughing
and cheering for and i will say this is
maybe very optimistic of the biden
administration's uh
next four years the way this is going
yeah i mean that's what i've been saying
for years
i've been saying it for months i've been
saying it for weeks it's coming this is
only the beginning did you see the meme
where the guys like day one of the
of the lockdown have you know haven't
really spoke haven't gone out yet i
wonder how this will go
day 90 i've baked a new bread recipe
it's going well day 310 well it seems
like a man with viking horns has taken
is now the president of the senate day
330. reddit's coordinated attack on wall
street is going as planned
you forgot that you forgot the three
masks and the
buttocks probes uh a part of that three
masks
which by the way by the way dr fauci
came out today on national television
said there's no data showing that two
masks work
recommending yes yes yeah he literally
said that he literally was on national
television
and he was like there's no data that
that talks about that that it makes any
difference
after saying last week that it's common
sense for people to wear two masks
again another major flip-flop and if we
go into the kobit 19 thing
what about all the national guardsmen
troops that are coming down with covet
we're also hearing that there's a
massive cover-up with the national guard
troops
uh that's covering up hundreds of them
that are
put into very close quarters sharing a
small amount of restroom facilities not
being able to shower not being able to
sleep properly
getting a ton of coven and there's no
mainstream media hysteria
about a super coveted spreader event
like there was with the alleged
insurrection
which is again just another layer of
hypocrisy here that needs to be unfurled
so people
understand through the bull crap the
reality that we live in
so i'm i'm just watching everything kind
of fall apart and then i go
out to today to go you know we're gonna
go grab some i had to run some marines
go to post office go grab some food and
everything was closed and you know i
mentioned it earlier in the show
went to a mexican restaurant just closed
no signs in the door and i was confused
what's going on they're supposed to be
open
kfc was closed some other local
restaurants were closed
and then i was just like you know what
that's it we're in a simulation
and they're drawing down the computing
power so now there's no people anywhere
ever like
people aren't in the streets anymore
because they're inside because of covet
the restaurants are all closed
the media narrative is breaking the
system is falling apart
and i'm like is it is it because the
simulation is like running it's it's
course it's expired now
and so like the the the simulation when
they're just turning down the power
and now there's nothing left to do and
we're on the verge it's like the end is
now no no no no we're getting into the
final chapters we're getting we're
getting to the end boss
when it gets really interesting when it
gets really difficult in my opinion but
also
nbc news last week they cited someone
that said you need four masks
four masks on an nbc news article
recommended by the media dr fauci common
sense last week this week
luke if nbc is recommending four masks
then
it's common sense that five masks would
just be better
no no six would be better than five yeah
yeah you just got to do more math
more is always better yeah listen you're
wrong
if if six masks would be good then it's
common sense
that's seven minutes that's a good point
oh yeah
good conversation thanks guys
i got an idea let's just make a video
where we wear as many masks as possible
see how far we can get yeah i'm still
sick
i can't breathe well you'll be passing
it on because you'll be dead
yeah mother your sleep with a pillow i
uh i gotta i'm looking for an article
right now about
uh a scientist coming out and saying it
is almost i think he might have even
said that it's definitive that covet was
made in a laboratory
wow did you what's the source okay i
gotta find this stupid
there's so much politics involved in in
a lot of these stories i'm just like
look man it's been a year i don't care
let's just have a surgical reopening of
businesses get people their lives back
100
and the discussion of origin at this
point isn't gonna isn't gonna save you
know
you know bob and sally's mom and pop
shop and that's what i'm worried about
so what's done is done you know the new
york mag ran that article i get it
but uh oh new york mag ran that new york
man the lag
lab leak hypothesis article so you know
youtube wants to ban
people for bringing it up and then media
matters smears you if you do and then
new york meg and huffington post are the
ones who actually promoted it it was in
may
washington post ran the lab league
hypothesis but now i'm sitting here like
it's a distraction in my opinion
getting people to talk about the origin
doesn't change the fact that it is cuomo
it is these democrat governors and many
republican governors
who have chosen to destroy your life
like it maybe it would help us
learn how to deal with it if we
understood if it was human-made or if it
was naturally
understanding the origin i don't know no
the the lab leak hypothesis isn't that
it's human-made
oh what is it it's that they were trying
they took the virus and they were trying
to develop a vaccine for it and it
leaked out of the lab
so they're actually i could be wrong i
think there is a portion that suggests
they were manipulating in an attempt to
develop vaccines
and that like it wasn't it wasn't made
in the sense that it
the lab was made as a weapon right right
right trying to be very carefully
because you know
it could be either or we don't have any
accurate
exact evidence we don't have any exact
evidence but we have a lot of theories
and we have a lot of
you know hypothetical information i just
don't think it's going to save is worse
it's worth people doing their own
homework their own research and making
up their own minds i think it's a
distraction at this point
i think i think we need to figure out
why they're destroying people's lives
and businesses and that's
that's the yeah and what made me think
about it is that you're saying the
national guards are getting it and it's
been
under-reported that they're being
stuffed into unsanitary conditions
well of course there's thousands of them
that were literally put into parking
lots
sleeping on top of each other there was
thousands of people sharing one bathroom
and having no facilities to shower and
clean themselves what do you think
that's going to
what do you think that's going to you
know had you know happening uh
what's his name um tony robbins really
had an interesting take about this thing
that that we can't even mention here
yeah i tweeted about it we can't even
say exactly what we'd be in the bonus
segment
uh yeah i think in the bonus section
let's talk about the cfr i
tweeted that video under under luke we
are change eye opening video we should
play it later on in the special
all right so let's do this because we do
have another segment i want to talk
about
before we move on we'll do a bonus
segment after this show
talking about what masks
labs covet all that stuff and what's
being reported what's being said
and this is our safe space at
timcast.com
where believe it or not even though it's
members-only content we can still
they'll still come after us
no joke i could imagine because they can
be you can be you can be charged for
things that you've done off the site
youtube will ban you for things you've
said on other platforms you've got to be
vigilant but we're gonna we're gonna
we'll we'll talk about it
and we'll go through these things
because as far as i'm concerned i think
it's only a matter of time before they
nuke us off these platforms that's why
we're getting
that's why we're doing independent i
mean i'm not going to say anything that
i don't already say on my youtube
channel
right but we're just going to have to be
careful how we say it with the official
sources
with of course you know the documents
with of course in a way
where it's done honestly so there's no
excuse to to ban anyone or to hit anyone
or to strike anyone because
i mean we literally dot our eyes cross
our t's we make sure that everything
that matters
all the information it doesn't matter
but but at the end of the day it does
factor in
so there is a factor to this that that
makes the people in the middle who are
watching this who are not knowing what's
going on
that's the people you got to play for
you got to play for the people in the
middle
who who haven't made up their mind yet
and if you could show them without a
without a doubt that you did your job
correctly you looked at
at everything you provided accurate good
information to the people
and and if they still hit you for that
you're going to gain a whole lot
let me let me let me just say one thing
real quick um because i want to segue
into this next segment
and then we'll do some chats after it
but if you go to timcast.com
we actually have an entire bonus episode
it's 45 minutes long talking about
epstein
and a bunch of those things that youtube
would absolutely ban us for
and so that's if you're a member you'll
get that and then we're gonna we're
gonna you know we're gonna go ham we're
gonna we're gonna talk some of this i
wanna make this world a better place
this is what i'm doing why i'm here
and i know that people that run youtube
and google know that free speech
is one of the core tenets of what will
help us democratize this planet
and i also understand you're running a
website and you need to moderate it and
make sure that things don't spiral out
of control so conspiracy theories can
confuse people
but i i believe that we are on the same
path
and that we want to help people so bro i
think that talking about these things in
a balanced way is
what makes you incredibly important what
makes you think youtube believes in free
speech well youtube's
just a company name i think that the
people that work there
from my experience because i was with
youtube before google bought them
and chad hurley was the man and the
essence of youtube being able to make
video and put yourself out there to
speak your truth
is is still prevalent and google liked
that and that's why they bought it and
they want to subsidize it so that people
can make a living doing that
jack dorsey and mark zuckerberg don't
care at all well i'm not worried about
twitter and facebook right now youtube
doesn't either
um they they just that's a corporate
company name i mean i don't know
why the company doesn't susan which
doesn't care about free speech
they will they will ban you in two
seconds they do not agree with you they
believe that free speech in the spread
of ideas
results in some rabbit hole
radicalization nonsense i just don't
want to assume
i don't want to say it's not an
assumption i don't want to assume what
they think actions speak louder than
words
they have yeah but i wouldn't judge
people's future based on what they did
in the past
what like just because they said some
stupid stuff back in the days
thousands of users they purged one
percent of the entire website
well they're running about it to a bunch
of media outlets about how they were
doing the right thing
all right they don't agree with your
right to say you speak your mind i get i
just i understand
i empathize with trying to moderate a
billion person website
i get it but why would they ban
conservatives just because a
conservative has an opinion where he's
like i'm critical of immigration
banned you're both both of you guys are
right and i think the the scenario here
is as unfolding as
you guys both see it but i think there
is a small chance in what ian is saying
that there's a middle person
that could say well they actually did
everything by the book they did
everything correctly they actually
provided a service
that's good and might not report it to
the higher-ups so so
that might be the opportunity and chance
that you're right but but you're right
at the end of the day
if someone at the top wants to strike
someone down if you want to hit a dog
you're always going to find a stick
that's what my dad always told me but
uh if you want to hit a dog you're
always going to find a stick what does
that mean that means
don't push your luck don't just keep you
know uh bundling your head and
and thinking that you know you're the
essence
i was walking through the woods trying
to find a stick to throw for a dog to
play fetch and it took me a little while
to find the actual stick and i don't
want to you know i just wanted to play
fetch
okay whatever you know
you proved his theory correct exactly or
at least you so so
at the end of the day that the person
that's on the top that's making these
bigger kind of generalized orders
he could he or she could only do so much
right so so
they can't just ban outright everyone
all the time
and we should never give them an excuse
to to
give them uh any reason to do it we
gotta do we're gonna do one more segment
and then we'll do super chats but uh
and this one you know this will probably
be like 10 or 15 minutes or so but check
out the story
it's not the biggest story in the world
but it needs to be talked about
swat team sweeps homeless out of
washington state hotel that was taken
over by activists this should be
major news check this out two olympia
police swat teams two teams
went door to door at the red lion hotel
sunday night breaking up what police
called a forcible occupation
by homeless advocates other officers
escort out employees who were sheltering
in the basement for more than six hours
feeling trapped police said
seven people were detained seven people
were detained
are more and more arrests are expected
cbs affiliate cairo tv reports
the incident was similar to one seen
recently in fife washington
the activists from a group called oli
housing now paid for 17 rooms for one
night
moved in 33 homeless people and tried to
arrange for them to stay
indefinite without paying they demanded
that thurston county use funds from
fema to pay for rooms we we're just
ready to stand our ground
we don't mean any harm we actually want
this hotel to get
business that's the opposite of what's
going to happen by the way
police said they started receiving calls
at about 11am from hotel employees who
said people with batons
knives hatchets gas masks helmets and
goggles
had entered the lobby apparently
prepared for a confrontation
once officers estimated there about 45
members of the group inside and out
now they just had batons knives hatchets
gas masks helmets and goggles but they
don't mean any harm
the knives are for buttering their bread
of course and and and making toast for
the homeless
the batons are for playing wiffle ball
out in the backyard and the masks those
are just to look cool oh everyone's got
to wear a mask it's kovan
they were being conscientious when they
decided to take over a hotel
i see you've done your due diligence
what you've
you've obviously looked into this no i'm
just i just read i read the story
these people have staged an armed
occupation of a hotel
a private hotel that's right okay have
you heard did you hear about this
no but i'm kind of glad the swat team
came in and yeah and cleared them out
two swat teams wow raided a hotel
because
like far left activists with weapons
were threatening
hotel employees because they're
desperate for a place for people to live
yeah in the winter yeah and you know the
the it does underscore very serious
problems we have in in
in our country you know i was talking
about
jon stewart uh earlier he tweeted that
i guess in response to getting smacked
around by like these these late night
hosts
over his uh pro wall street bets comment
he said so if i do good at this do i
become president and then i was like
yeah
become president what do you do run on
your unrelenting support for 9 11 first
responders
i'd totally vote for that no really i
would totally vote for that
jon stewart's awesome and the point i
was making is that
we will send 10 million dollars to
pakistani gender gender studies programs
you know for for what reason i have no
idea we'll send billions of dollars in
foreign aid
while we have people sleeping on the
streets now i'm not saying the solution
is just giving these people homes or
taking over a hotel
i worked for a homeless shelter i've
worked for non-profits the problem is
extremely complicated
many of these people are not well they
can't work even if they want to because
they're not well so what do we do we
don't just throw them in the street
well what happens is when our government
takes our money our tax dollars when
they print massive amounts of money
they strip our value away and their
buddies rip us off
they send that money overseas for god
knows what
and they do nothing to solve the problem
yeah and you end up with a bunch of
angry people who show up with batons and
that doesn't solve the problem either
but hey i can respect the anger to be
honest
i'm sick of what i'm sick of the money
being wasted on nonsensical
bull crap i don't understand how the
flint crisis went as
went on as long as it did with them
screaming and everyone
knowing and every lifting i have a
secret advocacy group saying
these pipes are getting led in the kids
mouths and it's like yeah but
gender studies in pakistan you know they
need money for those programs right
yeah and where did they get the money i
mean we're talking about income tax
sales tax
property tax capital gains tax which a
lot of people are going to be finding
out about very soon especially if you're
on reddit
inheritant tax i mean when you look at
the rate that the american people are
tax i mean it's not as high as europe
but
when when you add it all up it's it's
absolutely incredibly
uh jaw-dropping to understand how much
money the government
takes and then where do they spend the
money as you said you know
speed boats for sri lanka that was
literally in the budget bill in fact
that was passed what's going on in
myanmar
i hear there was a military revolution
well that's a whole nother topic
has that been funded by but this is
another before we jump there i want to
finish on this topic here particularly
because
when you look at the homeless situation
it's about to get way
way worse not only because of the larger
financial tsunami coming our way from
the ramifications of the 2020 lockdowns
which they're coming
which we still haven't felt the full
ramifications of it's
going to hit people and it's going to
hit people hard economic flows usually
take months
usually even takes sometimes years to
fully affect people but this is another
thing we need to realize here
a lot of the homelessness issues are
surrounded mental health
mental health is plummeting in the
united states at a dramatic rate
when we see suicides self-harm
depression
going dramatically down and that's going
to cause another extreme situation
and when you have extreme situations
people are going to see extreme
solutions just like those people
in the hotel and i'm not i don't want
this to happen what we're seeing is the
extraction of the system at the very
last minute
i think that the the establishment
elites the politicians the wall street
bankers the big ceos and all the stuff
they've given up they're looking at
everything and they're like ship's going
down
what should we do well grab as much of
the fine china and silverware as you can
get to and get to an escape boat and
then get out before anyone realizes the
ship's sinking
ship going down that's that's what it uh
that's what it feels like it feels like
the homelessness crisis the the
evictions that are looming
the fact that people aren't getting cash
right now their their businesses have
been destroyed
the ship is about to crash they know it
and so they're just like
let's just take what we can yeah they're
printing as much as they can buying as
much land as they can
investing in as much stock and stuff
that's going to be not investing right
shorting the stocks to make sure that
they're look they printed all this money
most of it goes to these massive
corporations they pay out their bonuses
they buy land they buy hard assets then
the dollar tanks then what
they leave you holding the bag
homelessness is pretty nasty i
agree with you i've also seen that some
people with mental disabilities or
whatever that are just are not in a
position that even if you give them a
place to stay
a job and a bunch of money they're gonna
fail and land right back on the street
there are some people like that
but there are many people that are
homeless and what they need is a shower
and a bed they need a shower so that
they can clean themselves
so that they can become presentable to
get the job because if you stink
you're not going to get the job they
need a a shower they need a clean shirt
they need a haircut they need to shave
and it's really hard to do when you live
nowhere right you have nowhere to go and
so
that's why i do like these shelters i
don't know
if we'll ever find a solution because
sometimes people become
destitute sometimes people you know they
can't re repurposing
empty buildings for homeless people why
is that not why is that not more common
who maintains the building i don't know
who where's the money come from they've
tried that in the past
and the buildings fall apart and they
become ghettos and then crime and
disease
it is a very real problem that we need
to find the root of and get to the root
of but
the reality is sometimes people become
homeless because they don't have the
mental
health required and i don't mean they're
crazy some people are too depressed
and it's a serious issue some people
have
schizophrenia some people have you know
psychotic disorders need medication
some people can't afford the medication
you get left with a large group of
people that
are just basically thrown to the gutter
and we have no real easy way to solve
the problem
it may not be a problem that can be
solved to be honest but we can mitigate
it properly
i don't think occupying a hotel solves
the problem in fact it's probably going
to make it worse not by force definitely
not
well ian we already have that we already
have section 8 housing we already have
projects
so there's government buildings where
people live in so
and they function of course you gotta
you gotta fly through hoops to get
into section eight like whereas a
homeless shelter you just walk in and
stay
if you look at this uh the you know
poverty rates it's usually a cycle that
just keeps
spinning itself into oblivion with the
way that the system has
established itself that essentially
screws people over
with either too much taxes too much
regulations too much on them
that decentifies anyone from from any
kind of economic mobility because
there's barely any left
you're talking about low-skill jobs
they're replaced by immigrants you're
talking about high-skill jobs
they're replaced by visa programs for
immigrants
and then companies like elon musk get in
trouble for not hiring enough immigrants
so so where's the where's the upward
economic mobility
there isn't a non it's a scam it's all a
big system
where people with within the banking
system literally print zero
onto a computer and that's how our
financial system is run meanwhile
everyone else what do they do
they they get stuck in this poverty
cycle that they never get out of because
there's no way out of it i'm thinking
two things either ubi
we print a bunch of money doesn't seem
to work and then this microsoft patent
zero six zero six zero six where we
implant
you know chips in these people and then
just their biometrics can earn their
cryptocurrency so that they have so many
just for being what if
i don't think implanting was anything
having to do with it they might not have
to plan you could do a tattoo it could
be something you eat i don't know but
you put something in them
or on them so that it measures their bio
activity maybe a watch so that you know
are they looking at the billboard if so
they earn cryptocurrency just sit there
and watch them
i have a conspiracy theory what's that
ian's the elite
someone else said i was an arm of the ad
that i'm the avatar of the ai
on twitter yeah someone suggested why is
it because of these things i'm talking
about maybe i'm just like
you're encouraging because that would
lead us towards the matrix where people
are in pods like generating heat for the
system this giant machine
that's like controlling everything but
otherwise we have homeless people
all over the street hitler's idea was
kill them he would he would
wrap up all these mentally you know ill
people and just have them killed
because they were ruining his society
that i don't want to do um the matrix is
terrifying putting people in pods but
what do you do they're on the street
if they can't if they can't take care of
themselves there's poop everywhere
what do you do because we're animals
we're wild barely tamed animals and if
we're not mentally prepared
what do what kind of bet what do we do
no idea i
look i worked for homeless i've worked
for a homeless shelter a network
there's no solution you know a lot of
homeless people refuse to go to shelters
and refuse to get jobs
that's another problem what do you do
you can't solve the problem they
they refuse you'll you'll you'll pull up
and you'll say
we've got a clean shower we've got a bed
we've got clothing and you don't got to
do anything you can just live there
they'll go nah
i don't want to work for your system no
there's no work involved
literally we i i worked for a shelter
that would offer people
no questions asked room and board at a
house
you get your own key you come in the
back door you go right to your room no
one asks you any questions you have a
house you have a shower you have clothes
no they wouldn't take it
but but it's so in the meantime they're
out on the street just like polluting
the environment whatever literally like
crapping on the ground
blocking traffic terrifying people that
are walking by
so one one place in northern california
wants to rendition
that's probably the wrong word but they
want to take them and then gain power of
attorney over their finances
and that's part of the justification is
that you give these people even an
opportunity for a free place to live and
they refuse what do you do
so now they're saying they have the
right to just take these people for
mental health reasons and lock them up
see that leads towards what hitler looks
like hillary clinton absolute tyranny
absolute if like if somebody wants to
sit on the sidewalk
and you know in most places it's legal
to do you can't block the sidewalk
but they can't arrest you for being in
public and sleeping they'll
they they do sometimes uh in many places
they probably do
but in san francisco they'll get up
every morning if my friend kelly cutler
is like a community organizer for the
home of san francisco they'll come at
like 4am with firehoses
just hose everybody on the sidewalk
it's pretty bad i think san francisco is
a really good example of what happens
when you have an
oligopoly when you've got zuckerbergs
and dorsey's controlling the system
and they're ultra wealthy elites who
pretend to be good people
dorsey's probably the worst because he's
like this hippie guy who talks about all
these great things
and then he's just a billionaire who
funds critical race theory and then
people are crapping on the street and
homeless and destitute but at least he
can fund critical
race theory right like that's solving
the problem solving the problem
homeless people come in from all
different backgrounds these these people
in silicon valley just want you to think
they're doing a good thing
so that way when you come with your
pitchfork you ignore them because
they're the good guys right
meanwhile they're actually making the
problems worse
yep yes i'm at a loss
yeah you know what what really
frustrates me is that
it's the grifters it's the grifters man
what do you mean
there are people on the the there's
establishment individuals who pretend to
be on the left
who would waste their time pulling
quotes from me out of context for for
the goal of making a partisan rage bait
piece of content so like jimmy kimmel
no no no i'm talking about people on
youtube who are grifters
who take clips from this show out of
context you're talking about specific
people you're not naming
and they cut and edit them so that they
get you
or or luke or me saying things and then
they they
they use that so that people don't want
to listen to what we have to say
because if they did they'd be like hey
we we actually think a lot of the same
things we have green a lot of same
things wrong don't worry too much about
that stuff no
that that is the problem we're trying to
unify the people
against the the machine that is
stripping our value away and destroying
our lives
and what happens is you get grifters
useful idiots for the establishment
who go on their shows take clips out of
context from shows like this
and then say tim pool is far right when
like literally i'm pretty sure the
entire bent of this show has been fairly
left-wing
pro-social programs for the homeless
talking about wall street being bad
you'd think it would be a pretty
left-wing positive you know i did say i
like those swat teams
going in there and oh you're far right
that was kind of far right we were
pretty pro-gun
i guess that's a problem someone cut me
up and made me look really stupid
i'm already pretty stupid but like holy
cow that's not fair
why'd you do that i need more memes so
cut me up come on well
i'll be fair we did this thing on
jacobin where we looked at the magazine
cover
oh yeah fine as jesus and we were like
laughing at them but the greater context
of the segment was about how
the left in general the establishment
left not the progressives
were overwhelmingly praising biden with
like sun the sun
clouds breaking and sunlight beaming
down on the inauguration and we were
just using the jacobin thing as a
launching point
but but to be fair we did not realize
initially
that it was meant to mock the exact same
thing however in that podcast we did say
oh man wait a minute there's drones on
the cover this is
probably parody it's like satire and
then i said well if it is you know we
deserve we deserve it right
the problem was you could have taken the
episode and watched it
and then been like guys we completely
agree with you you missed this though
we were agreeing with you the whole time
and i'm like no look at that instead
it was used by a bunch of leftists to
mock and deride and insult this show
even though they agree with us
why why they agree with we agree with
them it's easy clicks
exactly these people are destroying our
opportunity to call out the
establishment i would say in regards to
that jacobin thing
i i said it earlier i don't think text
flies with sarcasm you don't see it when
you see text and same with
images you can't tell if that's sarcasm
or not i mean for me it's like whatever
it's okay you did it i'm just gonna keep
focusing on my mission and my job and my
goals and i'm gonna try to reach them
i'm going to try to help as many people
as i can
and if they want to do that let them do
it but at the end of the day
no it's not going to be lazy it's not
personal it's about
right now we have on reddit these people
going after the machine and it's working
and we have a non-partisan issue where
everyone kind of agrees we're seeing
donald trump jr and aoc agree on the
same thing
the issue is not personal i don't care
if you call me a bunch of stupid names
and mock my appearance like they do well
i don't care
it comes the territory don't expect to
get into public you know spaces
and think everyone's gonna love you just
not reality the issue i'm worried about
is not it's not personal
it's about how they do this to anybody
who might actually agree with them
that the tribe is more important than
the cause they will mock
like you ian uh probably agree with a
lot of these left-wing personalities
substantially more
than anyone we've had on the show like
especially criticisms of donald trump
but they would cut segments up of you to
make you look
like you're far right instead of just
being like we like this guy
because it's more for them the tribe is
more important than the cause
so my concern is we want to get people
to rally around what we all agree on and
build culture and community and support
for the things we can accomplish but the
grifters
are the ones who are destroying that
because they're more interested in
clicks and rallying people to hate each
other what we can do is not grift
if we can well we don't yeah i don't i
really
don't think i do i really do not i try
not to take people out of context man
that
that what was that kid who who had the
native american dude in his face and he
was smiling
right covington i took that i i almost
snapped on that and that that was a
wake-up call for me to take
mistake of taking people out of context
we'll have anybody from left right up
down whatever on this show
we clearly have you and i we have our
arguments you'll be very critical of
trump i wanted to argue with you more
today
[Laughter]
but but it doesn't it doesn't work for
them so like the one segment they did
where they made
where we were talking about jacobin they
had to edit it
to make luke look stupid because they
completely agreed with luke and every
point he was making but the democrats
so they made it seem like how do you
even get to see the image
i was just generally talking about the
larger principles of not worshiping
someone
who's in politics you shouldn't don't
they can't they
there can't be a podcast where there's
actually kind of a moderate view on
things
so they have to edit it out of context
but it's not personal it's more about
hey on the upside our our show about
jacob and got i don't know half a
million views whereas the clips probably
got
a third of that or you know this show is
getting more views than those clips
so that's a good sign well you know i
just wish people would maybe i think i
don't know
the tribalism is a problem that being
said let's go to super chats we're in a
little long but uh we'll read your super
chats i'm gonna dip for a minute and
then we're gonna have
uh we're gonna have a bonus segment
talking about lab league hypothesis
covid and where we're currently at
that'll be at timcast.com so make sure
to be coming
become a member hopefully it'll be up
around 11 or so but
you know upload times because this is a
straight upload we just do a segment
after the show
let's read some super chats if you
haven't already smash the like button
subscribe notification bell
man i ask her a lot don't i yes angry
fish thanks for the super chat
we got benjamin saying make the right
decisions in pursuit of freedom
slap down my machine founded on
protecting freedom why to protect suits
and their pocketbooks
cargo says sro self-regulating
organization
it is an organization that is given
power by the federal government to
regulate a market
ah okay oh so it is essentially a
regulator
all right we i wanted to be careful so
we changed the initial title but thank
you guys
let's see al ghul
says follower forever this is my first
super chat you don't understand the
attack on silver it's not
shares that wss wants to kill it's
physical silver
because it's been shorted for 50 plus
years alex jones has covered this
i think we mentioned a little bit about
that but right they're telling everyone
to buy the shares
and everyone else saying no no buy the
actual physical silver
let's see md noslew says
hi i'm tim poole i'm rich but i need you
to send send me more money to tell you
what you already know
uh hi i'm tim poole i'm rich and i run a
business where if you like getting this
content you can watch for free
for 99 of that content sometimes with
ads or the sponsor read
and if you really the content and would
like to pay for a product that we
produce
you can go to timecast.com and become a
member it's a really weird thing to me
about
running a business like if i spent time
making you a sandwich and then asked you
to pay for it most people would be okay
with that
but there's a weird thing where online
people are like don't don't give money
to this business for the products they
produce because they already have money
it's like
okay yeah you don't have to i don't know
greatly appreciate it when you do
i remember for a long time being scared
to ask for donations
and just being like oh and feeling
really awkward about it but it's like if
you want to support us people should
know where to support us well
listen the memberships at timcast.com
come with a product
we produce exclusive content yeah we
so we've added more work to our day to
produce something
which creates two paths for us to
maintain the business
99 is all free content it's all free
and we just rely on ad sponsorships and
super chats
so it's basically like a pay what you
will model you don't have to super chat
if you don't want to
and then we have the membership thing
where we produce content that is ad free
completely
and we and uncensored and for those that
are willing to buy that product
sometimes it's awkward to market your
own products that's why people will hire
marketing firms to do it for them and
why is an actor you have an agent to go
do it for you so you don't have to be
the one that's like hey can i come in
and it's similar with with timcast.com
like
i think people are like tim why but like
dude who else is gonna do it right now
me go to timcast.com and sign up
well look if you if yeah no look it's
simple man we could always hire a
marketing firm to do some youtube ads
for us
we've got millions of subscribers across
the board we have the best subscribers
and we've got like .001
of those who are members it's fine it's
not even members
have you just closed the numbers of how
many members we have no no
it's growing fast it is too fast guys
you said oh no
keep signing up hey i got my first
donation you guys on twitch
i got twitch.tv and i um
i started using stream labs which is
like an upgraded version of obs
to multi-stream and i set up like a a
marketing thing where i'm selling
t-shirts i'll talk more about it maybe
after the show's over
yeah and i got a donation personal
donation couple very important uh super
chats
crystal mac says please make a shirt
with rabble rabble rabble on it
i think that's a good idea i agree
nathan snyder says who wins godzilla or
king kong
very important super chat by the way
luke
um not a fan of either godzilla he can
like shoot lasers or whatever from his
mouth
yeah that can he yeah i think i thought
he could king kong is king kong
big monkey i think godzilla's like three
times the size of king kong isn't he
i have no one they changed it for the
new movie now they're the same size in
the new movie so that could they could
fight
so who would you pick i don't know i
gotta read the super chat
why z 250 moto says ian uh quote i want
to talk about vibrations of the universe
tim
quote shut your mouth
hey those were quotes today not today
all right here cryptic says only buy
physical silver stay away from slv as if
it
uh i'm not going to finish that super
chat but not financial advice by the way
just a random internet comment
uh i i've got some physical silver not
really enough i've never been good at
investing
unless it's investing in myself so if i
was
good at like being part of the club and
the one percent i'd probably have way
more money than i do but all i do is
just run a business and then
not properly invest the silver mines too
that's a good investment
i think i've heard i'm not a financial
analyst so
uh let's see we got one from cp says
longtime listener i love the show i'm
going to join timcast.com tonight
also i would love to hear what george
carlin would have to say about
everything going on right now i wish man
george carlin was the man we got rogan
keeping it real yeah and carlin's uh
he's like carlin's protege
so this one this one's funny uh let's
see we actually interviewed uh carlin on
the
weird change channel before he passed
away wow is that on youtube yeah
that's awesome um yeah he said something
very important things about 911
we got the super chat from perrick s
tewari
the big short is the new contagion just
saw it again yesterday pretty good movie
except the big short is based on real
life yeah
the big short was 2008. a bunch of
people were basically like yo these
mortgage-backed securities
are stuffed with garbage they're
scamming people so what do we do
short it short at all and people are
like you're betting against the housing
market yup and they're like
okay you're nuts and they were right
what do they make like 800 million
dollars
too much but this is the reason these
people are considered folk heroes is
because they called
out the scammers who are ripping people
off and destroying everything
and they made a profit doing it good for
them
let's see ascendia media says dogecoin
is real grassroots the idea is to
leverage the power of a meme to
mainstream crypto
i get it that's the one good thing about
dogecoin making big news and people are
seeing it as a viable option to make
money and store their value
to me it's funny but like what's the
value of doge
if you guys have some specifics about
what it can do or or anything other than
the meme of the dog
i really want to get serious and tell me
because other than the goof
i'm not that's it that's why that's why
i don't care
it's it's like go with ethereum over
doge right there to be honest
i would like to buy me personally i'd
buy doge just to have it and never trade
yeah that's what i did
yeah it's just gonna sit and hold
storage because it's funny right
and it might be worth 10 million it's
kind of like buying a picture of gold
yeah you know what i mean it's like
putting it on your yeah it's something
you find putting in your safe
yeah yeah all right let's see we got
brent seigan says tim
please call out my brother grant for
listening to you for years but not
becoming a member on your website
please love god he keeps asking me to
show him the members only videos
and it's incredibly annoying come on man
there you go come on grant omegahunter9
says how do i get one of those cool
pictures when i leave comments on
timcast.com
uh you edit your profile that's it i
think i don't know
we are upgrading the whole site and uh
to be honest i i had people who'd done
it on paypal
for a long time and i didn't realize how
big the influx would be
if we started the website but my friends
let me tell you something
i believe based on your memberships the
only thing stopping us
from rivaling the young turks in terms
of network
and access and everything is time uh
i'm fairly confident you know and i'm
not saying this to be disrespectful uh
to the youngers at all i'm using them as
sort of like a marking
of where uh independent channels can be
on youtube
we've surpassed i've my channels have
surpassed them in views a long time ago
i did reduce the amount of content i
produced so it may have normalized but
now with the memberships
it's a very real possibility we get we
can start like a 24-hour network
higher on more personalities do separate
shows and really expand this
in ways i've never i didn't totally
expect i'll just put it this way
i did not think that many would that
many people would sign up so quickly and
so many did i'm like
okay now we need to rapidly expand what
you get for that membership
and it's probably gonna be big yeah it's
probably gonna be i've been thinking a
lot about expansion the last
we're gonna we're gonna need to start
new shows we're gonna need to do live
streams
and we might even we might even able we
might even do
like a 24-hour live thing so what that
would really be though
you know we're gonna start slow we're
not just going to start with 24 hours
and have all these different hosts and
everything
but the amount of people who signed up i
just got to say it's substantial
and now i'm like okay let's do this we
can just do 24-hour stream in the skate
park with like a vip
camera section where you can go up there
sit down and talk to the camera 24 7
streaming
we could literally have like seven
shows where it's like the 3 p.m to 4 p.m
show is like the you know so and so in
the in the park with guests
and then we we really are on the verge
like of
rivaling i've been streaming games i
would love to integrate that into the
network
like a 2pm gaming stream for an hour
there's a there's a lot more that i i
can't necessarily say about the
expansion
but uh it's good news for those who are
investors
in subverse now scanner we are working
on this
on this project and this will be really
really good news for everybody
i'll just leave it at that and we'll
read more super chats
uh i will i will lightly touch on it too
there were some issues i don't know if
we sent out
the letter to the investors yet but we
fully plan
like covid really jammed up this the
scanner project in
in ways we could not foresee getting
physical space hiring people was all
completely shuttered because
essentially couldn't operate in cities
but we do have we are working through
the kinks
and we plan on doing a big launch soon
and that's what i'm talking about
you have a news department a gaming
department a music department and a tech
department and
a media department oh it's going to be
big this is going to be big you guys are
awesome by the way
ryan ryan says the latest stock td
ameritrade shutdown was hcmc
in otc with their fight against philip
morris i'm sure because our wall street
vets talked about it
interesting carl flynn says i highly
recommend the book green eyes and black
rifles by kyle lam for practical rifle
shooting
the man spent decades in sf and delta
and i train my marines using the tp
ttps in the book cool very cool very
interesting
we went out to uh the middle of west
virginia last weekend
fire shot a rimfire 50 bmg no no breach
floating there's a reach loading
fire yeah and whatever it was it was
powerful it was
smaller than i thought it was going to
be really well because
you didn't want to shoot it i didn't
want to shoot no i didn't it was uh
there's it's on your instagram yeah
there's video of it yeah it's intense
luke luke fired it and i was standing
slightly to the left and the shock wave
shut my phone off
i was i was i was filming luke and then
after the
after he fires the shock wave hits me
and then i look at my phone's off
whoa yeah and then so you're like push
to the off button
i have no i have no idea how it happened
i don't know yeah it's there's a lot of
force
uh it's something else dude in the
youtube video on on it or on the
instagram video of luke you seem like
crawling up on the gun he's like getting
all like
like he's crawling through the mud and
then he's just like just
wicked shock yeah it's remarkably simple
how the how the breach load works it's
just you screw it off you put it in you
screw it on you pull the hammer back and
click that simple it's no semi-auto
bearing though
nope it is nope
let's see gurg c says tim you guys are
killing me
spacex because of dod satellite
contracts are not allowed to hire
non-americans
really that's weird we were just reading
the article yeah
eric miller says if occupies the bronze
age would wall street bets be the silver
age
then what's the golden age or what's the
in you know what came after the
silver age i don't know i don't know
after the bronze age was the
scar forget uh so there's actually a
couple more comments c hennessey
says musk explained in a q a that
because in its rocketry your employees
have to get military clearance
first before they can work this limits
employees oh for sure scar forget says
elon musk can't hire non-u.s citizens
because the rockets are considered a
national security issue
weapons of mass destruction uh
interesting
sees the memes of production says benny
ocean now that is amazing
so tesla hires foreigners not spacex
okay interesting
let's see ac 130 says i'm 26 i'm a
rapper from sc fighting the culture war
from the inside
hip hop's almost entirely woke now check
out my next album self-destruct sequence
2 on march 1st
love y'all hope to meet you someday i
just want to also point out
the easiest way to get an ad read on
this show is a super chat basically the
issue is we can't read every single one
that's what makes it hard but like
just shout out for this dude's uh album
self-destruct sequence 2 on march 1st
thanks for the super chats you see what
10 bucks can get you
yeah this gaming dragon says first time
super chat
tim is yotaro from jojo he can win at
poker by not folding and raising until
the other guy has a heart attack
by the way you guys should get salty
cracker if you haven't already
i don't know what that is i'll look that
up spasmodium says the next actual
squeeze is nokia by the way
well i'm not super convinced i did buy
nokia because
i like nokia you ever see that you ever
see the story about the guy who has a
nokia phone and a bullet goes through it
but stops no no
his life is saved by the phone there was
a meme for a long time that nokia phones
are indestructible it is still a meme
and it is still immediate i saw it just
recently so i saw the news and i was
like i actually
like tech has always been my jam my the
things i hold are typically like tech or
some kind of you know manufacturing
so i bought nokia because i actually
like nokia i don't care for the
you know i'm not i'm not going to sell
it i'm just going to sit on it forever
just because i like it but more
importantly like i
can't really buy any meaningful stock
and say google or
apple because it's too expensive so yeah
nokia was cheap so i could afford it
i have tesla i like tesla that's about
as expected as i got
yeah i just think of it as what
percentage of my net worth is going into
it i don't really worry about how much
the stock because you can buy like 0.2
of a stock or whatever oh okay tesla's
awesome though it's an awesome company
mr behavior says long time listener
first time caller i had to toss in a
super chat after luke's epic rant
unoffbro respect
i just became a member on timcast.com
recently wish you all luck with the site
and we need it um look so many people
signed up that we are like
bringing people on working overtime to
try and fix it and
like make it bigger because it's it it
it's taking off man you guys rock
spork which says registration leads to
confiscation
which leads to incarceration and
extermination literally every single
time
i like my guns like democrats like
voters undocumented
matthew walden says hr127 will bring
what you
fear maybe yeah i'm i'm not a fan of of
this crazy stuff
these crazy you know restrictions sean
anderson says i know i'm all i know i'm
old when you mention killdozer and my
first thought was the 1947 sci-fi made
for television movie starring clint
walker
it's on youtube check it out for a
chuckle that sounds fun nimitz says you
you have lied to locked up and destroyed
the businesses
of give or take 100 million draft age
males for over a year
then you shove the fact the american
dream is dead and every system is rigged
in their faces
the potter keg is lit yup
hands down garth thane says killdozer
was a
probably intentional media misnomer he
never actually killed anyone except
himself once the bulldozer finally got
stuck
yeah man was he shooting those guns yes
he did
jd 1989 says hi tim luke lydia and ian
house resolution 127 is outright
communist gun confiscation proposed by
representative jackson lee
this bill would disenfranchise all
low-income firearm owners and be
unilaterally illegal
well yeah yeah the the the taxes on a
gun i believe
has to be unconstitutional because it
would mean only which people can have
guns but they do it already with like
full auto you know
yep timothy peterson says how far could
hr 127 potentially go on a 50 caliber
ban
50 cal is the most popular black powder
black powder caliber
i wouldn't put it past them ricky bobby
says so louder with crowder started
again today huge news
they have filed a lawsuit against
facebook for removing their election
stream
the biggest independent stream removed
from the biggest platform for no reason
hope they win
i i do too good go go crowder they got
bill on it
isaac hilstrom says dogecoin we're going
back to the moon
okay marcus carter says 560 562 000
elected fish elected officials exist in
the us
if six million people can buy gme game
stock
why can't at least 562 000 americans
have the support to run for office
yeah yeah crowder said he might run for
office really i think he tweeted that
out
didn't mike cernovich tweet out that
he's running to be governor of
california wow
did he tweet that out am i wrong
interesting
eric hefflefinger says i've made six
wall street posts on facebook
dozen of picture video and news articles
each time one post at 57 picks
seven videos some being yours 23 news
articles dozens of people who i haven't
spoken to in years reached out
see i like the wall street thing man
it's bringing us together left and right
yeah that's why the grifters get me down
they're trying to stop that unity nah
people realize
that they're full of crap i hope most
people well now it's an opportunity to
show everyone yep daniel maxwell says if
there is not a peaceful resolution to
the culture split soon we will end up
with
a bloody civil war that is a guerrilla
warfare scenario
and what we end up with afterwards will
not be a constitutional republic
that is correct it is not going to be
good you do not want
guerrilla warfare no you just want to
buy an iron guerrilla
t-shirt and i am a gorilla t-shirt we
got more t-shirts coming
uh i think we're going to do one of ian
meditating
but floating so your hair is waving oh i
like that and then it says free the code
yes
yeah i love it yeah chakra colors behind
me yeah and then maybe
maybe we'll hide somewhere in the art
and the fed
oh yeah we're like we should do it we
should do an end the fed line
as well maybe or yeah
repeal the federal reserve act yeah
that's the web phrase
and the fed and we'll have like a little
ron paul in the background like giving a
thumbs up read the code dude
we need to free the code so that we can
build a free software system well the
the the free the code is more like your
actual catchphrase that's what i really
care about and like the end the fed was
more just kind of i was
brainwashed to say free the code by bill
though
i really do want to all right here we go
james king says
amc diamond hands and then six rocket
emojis
kristen f says this is how messed up the
gamestop stock thing is
i use a stock simulator app where i
invest fake money into stocks and watch
the market in real time
last week they took 8k of fake money out
of my account left me with 32
wait what fake money
why arios says i finally got a bit of
extra cash again so i'll share a bit
with the pool party
i'm going to rewind because i'm a bit
late but if you guys read this i just
want to say
that it always nice to listen at night
also wow
is that like supposed to be like waluigi
or something
i saw so many people were sad that we
didn't do a show on friday i loved it
we were wiped out man it was it was it
was it gave me a chance to make the
kombucha i'll be
i'll be i'll be honest with everybody it
was kind of frantic because
we had too many sign ups and it
overloaded and crashed the system
yeah i was actually working support that
night that eliza was on
we had so many emails that had to go out
that our site couldn't the next day was
just
like my brain was on like on fire so if
you both had headaches if you haven't
got
an email yet just stay stay cool
they're all coming out and if for some
reason by the end of the week you still
haven't gotten an email just send
another email these way to explain it is
that episode of simpsons where mr burns
goes to the doctor and the doctor says
that he has literally every disease
known to man
and so he says look at these oversized
novelty germs now one of them can easily
fit through the door but when they all
try going through at the same time they
get stuck
that's basically what happened and so
then once the door got jammed
every new signup was jammed and then the
automated system broke
and then it required manual intervention
so
uh success problems one by one one
by one we're all throwing in one by one
but uh we love it so sign up at
timecast.com it feels good every time i
would fix one
i'd be like yes that's a human that is
getting something
yeah all right here we go grant thompson
says you've got to see the urban
dictionary's definition for tds right
now very orwellian their ability to
rewrite definitions
and control a layman's perception of
reality yes the urban dictionary got
woke and so the
trump derangement syndrome which is a
reference to people who are irrationally
angry at trump turned into
people who irrationally support trump
wow yeah something like that
i think jeremy hambly made that uh made
that point when he was on the show
the quartering the tds can go in both
directions
irrational hate or an irrational love of
trump is both kind of a derangement
grant thompson says oh i just read that
one jonathan galterini says regarding
gun rights
you should look up arizona i'm from az
and was amazed how many restrictions
there are for guns in texas
az's safer than texas and they're blue
isn't that crazy
paul barnes says also i've been doing
construction on fort mccoy in wisconsin
and they've been shipping apcs out all
friday and today
not sure what for huh from where
this is uh uh fort mccoy in wisconsin
interesting
adam lynn says max started crash jp
morgan by silver
in 2010 causing them to change their
position
heard him give tim and luke a shout out
today during an interview saying 2021
is the year of the millennial very cool
max is a good friend we
we love max and stacy they're awesome
and uh yeah
we we've been trying to get them on we
uh were you were were you there in
france we were hanging out oh yeah
of course that was fun we like photos
stacy started following me on twitter
max and stacey i'm on the show guys we
were covering the climate protests
i think and then we all like had a crazy
night on the town which was really fun
it's nails
yeah when max and stacy come on i want
another chair because i want to
do all of us you guys if you're big into
crypto you should you should check out
their podcast it's the orange pill
podcast with max and stacey
we're just going to have you sit in the
middle and your head's going to pop up
did you do dmt
there you go yeah smoke dmt i want to
smoke dmt
i don't know but i feel like he'd have a
lot of really good opinions on it yeah
you know even though he's a finance guy
it was funny seeing that video he posted
of him in 1987
like young max kaiser talking about
stocks and ragging on yuppies i loved it
all right let's see let's see try and
get some more of these quentin
cooling says what do y'all think of tom
mcdonald's new song and getting to the
top of the chart
i listened to it today i was surprised i
was like those are some really strong
lyrics that were
for a lot of people the nail on the head
so he's charting he's
great like actual billboard charts or
what i think that he has i mean i know
he's big i don't think he has a
does he even have a label or a manager i
don't think he has any
okay so i have extreme respect for tom
mcdonald because he's doing all this
himself
yeah like him and his woman are making
this happen which is truly amazing and
he's very talented so i'll have to
listen to that and he got like three
million views
and just like uh just a very short time
and
the music video i mean i mean it was i
mean the lyrics were
profound i think what i love one of the
things i love about tom is his gratitude
he just he's got the essence of
gratitude to his fans
i kind of dismissed him for a while i
was like yeah whatever he's just another
like
white rapper i'm like whatever i i
there's enough white rappers
but then i started listening i listened
to the song today i was like whoa
like this is powerful stuff so he's got
a a bunch of his songs
are like honestly yeah it's like talking
cultural politics
white white boy he pays attention to
what's going on yeah so shout out to
them for doing we're
being smart and having something
conscious rather than the garbage
nonsense that's promoted by the
mainstream media and the main
music industry that wants you to be you
know sucking down cough syrup and some
drugs
so thank you for doing something
different that's right and uh we want to
get him on the show yes we will it may
it may at some point because we have
uh talked to him a bit and uh he's cool
dude so uh you know we'll just
early in the year bad weather you know
covid everybody's got you know
things that are kind of creating hurdles
for you know so there's a lot of people
we've actually had who will want to come
on the show that would be really really
awesome
and then they're like but maybe we
should wave after winter we had the
snowstorm we also have travel
restrictions so people are like
you know things things will kick up
there are some guests i don't i don't
like naming the people who we have
coming on but there's a lot of people
we're trying to get which will be
amazing conversations
like i wish i could say i can't though
but someone recently
we we i believe the pr company for one
very very high profile dude who was
cancelled
reached out to us and i'm hoping this is
a legit request because i would love to
have this dude on but i'm not going to
say who i contacted nassim harriman
about the source child proton
unification i was
at burning man with him he's great if
you know if you can get in touch we were
at the same camp together let him know
if you can i did a video
with him as well very interesting guys
he's basically seems to have solved
einstein's field equation
yeah liquefied field theory i talked
about that nassim harriman we are change
you'll see
me in a very interesting outfit at
burning man interviewing him
oh because we were at the same camp we
were sleeping together in the same uh
you know um you know group yeah he he
spent his years
working out of his van because the
scientific community wouldn't take his
work seriously because it basically
upended a lot of like accepted physics
but what he seems to have unified
um the universe there's some wild nights
into one energy form
so uh we had one super chat it was for
five dollars and said
here's here's for ian's uh contribution
to ian's rehabilitation
thank you sir and chris bell says ian
the things you say rip out pieces of my
soul tim how do you deal with it
lydia love your face hit your button
more so we can see that smile thanks guy
i think i know how tim deals with it he
puts me on his show
[Laughter]
yeah because uh i think for the most
part me and agree you know but when we
have our disagreements we voice those
disagreements we're like
really kind of logical and straight edge
but i play like a really wild
character on this show intentionally
because i think it's good to bring that
crazy
to the table i didn't realize you're
playing a character ian well i'm just
saying some of the most
out there stuff because who else is
going to say it and people need to hear
this because they need to question
themselves
we're not playing anything that's really
you i think it's like a hyper
exacerbated version of me hyper-inflated
version of myself he's putting up a
barrier now
like i just sit in silence if you really
want to see the real me watch my twitch
stream
yep there you go yeah i remember tim and
ian used to have these conversations at
the table
i was usually sitting like right between
them earlier today we talked about
the ideal gas law and about writing a
new there has to be at least one
screaming match in the house a day
just we were disagreeing earlier when
was he was talking about ideal
gas law and we were talking a lot
scientific laws and you were saying they
don't change i was saying science they
do
change theories change laws are
considered to be
i think laws scientific laws are there
until we figure out how to improve or
alter them
but neither of us really knew so we kind
of just yelled a little bit and then
moved on
i think i think theories are the ones
that's like we don't know for sure but
we've tested it this is what we believe
to be
correct and laws are like that's true
nassim if you're listening
settle this we'll just bring in a
scientist as i can explain it bring the
scene
let's bring this team on yeah you guys
know him reach out mike chilson says one
of my favorite quotes
the taxpayers are sending congressmen on
expensive trips abroad
it might be worth it except they keep
coming back
that's a good one all right let's see
hank bow horseman says hey tim has an
aspiring studying musician i'm a big fan
of the idea of creating culture but i'm
afraid of the potential social
ramifications of sharing music
especially with my uni any advice
don't be afraid just do it what are you
gonna do
don't have any regrets in life when
you're gonna look back at just your life
you're going to notice how fast it goes
and how you should have taken a lot of
those shots that you just denied
yourself
don't do that i take a lot of ridiculous
shots we're just talking about tom
mcdonald
yeah tommy what do you mean there lydia
i'm quite respectful of it tom mcdonald
makes uh
videos where he expresses his opinions
these songs and he's huge people love
this stuff
so there will be blow back but it will
be worth it
oh dude there's a ton of people who hate
my guts
and probably for dumb reasons probably
for frank reasons and many probably for
legitimate reasons jobs will be lost
friends will be will be lost but in the
long run it is
totally worth it oh yeah ryan says you
rule that is all appreciated
dj madero says all all the great things
are simple
and many can be expressed in a single
word freedom justice honor mercy hope
winston churchill great speech
excellent ed's world says what is
quantum
parse syntax grammar and why is it
important i don't know
turk longwell says i got in on
membership on day one haha
you got in you got past that the crowd
they rushed the door
jerome morrow says is your chicken
tenders giveaway only for new tim cass
members i'm already a member we're not
giving anybody
what no what have you done ian
all right we'll read a couple more of
these because then we're going to go
record this special segment
all right willie will billy the
hillbilly says hey ian wireless power
doesn't work due to power density in the
air
thousands of volt and hundreds of amps
will not only mess with electronics
wireless connections but it's also very
unhealthy and will basically cook you
you could send it through the earth i
think that's what tesla was
experimenting with
or through the ocean like um so there
are ways to ground the electricity and
then have it come out
i think interesting ooh ooh jonathan
mcclee says would love to see charlie
leduff the author of s
show the country's collapsing and the
ratings are great on your show
uh we we know charlie don't we luke
charlie the duff from detroit
is that jet charlie the um doesn't ring
i
i'm john come on we we know
i'll write this name down and see if i
can pick him up
yeah charlie yeah of course we know
charlie can you see him
yeah uh you know charlie he what did he
did a bunch of
bunch of virally viral videos for local
detroit news
well i'll i'll refresh your memory i
can't remember
i'll look him up he had a whole bunch of
really viral videos where he was doing
these amazing segments for detroit
local news okay i think i know what
you're talking about and he exposed a
lot of the government and mismanagement
and
waste yeah i think really funny ways
okay yeah yeah yeah
like you showed up someone's house like
a bathrobe or something someone you know
cheating the system exposed them and the
government that was doing something else
to
incompetent okay now we know it's been a
while though it's been a while
aj says you think ian's an average
non-intellectual guy whose reactions rep
the common man's ideas not so
he's high iq his uber creative weird
takes totally derail otherwise great
destruction
oh discussion get rid of him oh i didn't
realize i thought that was actually a
positive comment and then it kind of
just
i think it was like an imaginary comment
no that's just that's the square root of
a negative number
another old school great guy to have on
would be jimmy justice
who's that uh amazing guy uh that
was bringing street justice to parking
meter maids
in new york city oh the guy viral videos
yeah yeah yeah
no he did more than that it was
incredible sukiya drea says i signed up
on the website
right away and i've been enjoying the
vids i do small gaming streams as a
hobby and love
uh and and have love imagining joining
you lol love you guys keep it the good
work appreciate it
all right let's see let's do one more
here we go johnny max says have you guys
been paying attention to the coveted
restrictions
that are being put in place in canada
mandatory quarantines at undisclosed
government facilities upon arrival in
canadian airports
well i won't be flying to canada anytime
soon yeah check please they banned me
before
also western australia just put two
million people on lockdown because one
person got covered
oh my one person one yep i saw that
ladies and gentlemen we are gonna record
now a a special bonus
segment uncensored talking about the lab
leak hypothesis for kovid among some
other things
so make sure you go to timcast.com sign
up sign up to become a member
for those that are having any issues
with your membership serious apologies
we uh should have prepared better but we
have people standing by to make sure
that you can log in and get access and
they should be fixing all these things
right now and it should be good for all
new members so again if you sign up
in the past few days i'm terribly sorry
seriously about what happened but we are
working to get you guys
into the system to get it all working
and everything so we're gonna have a
bonus segment coming up
timcast.com don't forget to follow me on
twitter instagram and minds at tim cast
you can check out my other youtube
channels youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comtimcastnews
we're live monday through friday at 8pm
bona segments will be at timecast.com
luke what do you do uh i'm a t-shirt
vendor one of the t-shirts that i'm
wearing right now is another we are
change exclusives that says
maybe the day had a crappy you it
doesn't say crappy i had to tape over it
family friendly show you can get that
shirt
right now on thebestpoliticos.com
and that will support me being here and
if you want to know what i'm doing check
me out on we are change.org
thanks for having me well thanks for
being here luke
uh hey everybody i'm ian crossland and
uh you can follow me all over the
internet uh
especially youtube and um twitter at ian
crossland you can always follow me on
instagram and mines and
uh twitch where i'm streaming games
almost daily uh sometimes at night
sometimes during the day twitch.tv
ian crossland also if you're going to
email the website
make sure that if you email members at
timcast.com that it is
only for technical issues we have
another email that's for
uh if you want to give feedback and
things like that and what is that i
don't think we have that up yet okay we
don't have so we don't have a feedback
thing
just but we're gonna be setting up like
feedback and like and tips and stuff
i think there's been the ufo there's
other emails that we have
the spin that you spin the ufo at
gmail.com is good for any general
inquiry
so so limit your uh your emails so that
the technicians don't have to uh sift
through things that helps us out a lot
and you guys rock and roll yes i love
you
thank you guys all so much for joining
at the site we really really appreciate
it i'm really looking forward to
sticking it to these big platforms
one of which i'm on right now so i won't
say too much but i want to give a little
shout out to josh and his daughter noemi
who are watching tonight hi guys
i see you i hear you i'm sour patch lids
on twitter
and i'm real sour patch lids on gab and
instagram
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for hanging out we'll be back tomorrow
at 8 p.m
live and we'll see you all then bye guys
you